[Applause]
so
hey
good morning sir all right
what
good morning how are you today good
morning good morning
morning
you guys are gonna use this microphone
so
good morning judy
you hear everything okay today okay good
all right good morning
all right do we have any preliminary
matters before the jury comes out um
all right there's no objection to that
people change places here i just want to
make sure to look at the right place
okay
okay
i'm assuming it's
we tried
if it's a blank screen it's hard to see
if it's working or not
it is published
but it's just a blank screen i guess
okay we're gonna hope that's that's it
then
all right thank you anything other
else we have
all right ready for the jury
okay great
so
so
you can sit down
all right good morning ladies and
gentlemen if i can have you move your
water down by your chair does not have
anything there if we get electronic so
we mess up the electronics
i get in trouble so thank you uh i hope
you like the seat that you're in i'd
like to stay in that seat for the
duration i'd appreciate it i hope you
had a good evening all right thank you
and thank you for being punctual today i
appreciate it have a seat
all right
are you ready with opening statements
yes all right go ahead sir
good morning
my name is ben chu
my colleagues and i from brown rudnick
are truly honored to represent the
plaintiff in this case
johnny depp
some of you may recognize mr depp from
seeing him portray characters such as
edward scissorhands or captain jack
sparrow from the pirates of the
caribbean movies
for nearly 30 years
mr depp built a reputation
as one of the most talented actors in
hollywood
a respected artist whose name was
associated with success at the box
office
today his name is associated
with a lie
a false statement uttered by his former
wife
the defendant amber hurd
that falsely cast mr death falsely
unfairly
characterized
cast mr depp as a villain
a man
who would violently abuse a woman
this is a defamation case
it's a case about how devastating words
can be
when they are false and uttered publicly
under the law a person who makes a false
statement about someone else
can be held responsible for the harm
that results from that falsehood
that's because words
matter
they paint a picture in our mind based
on what we have experienced and what we
know
or what we think we know
and because of that words can evoke
strong emotions in the listener and
cause irreparable harm to a person's
reputation
and when like mr depp your career
depends upon
your image and your reputation
or whether movie producers want their
films associated with you
that harm can be particularly
devastating
this is a case about the impact of amber
herds
words on johnny depp
specifically the words that she used in
an op-ed
published in the washington post
in december 2018
which is shown on the screens
and the op-ed was published
and this is no accident the evidence
will show
on the eve of her first major acting
role in the movie aquaman the evidence
will show that's no coincidence
the evidence will show the words that
misheard used
which are the subject of mr depp's
defamation suit against her
and there are three statements that we
respectfully ask each of you to focus on
statement number one
quote
i spoke up against sexual violence and
faced our culture's wrath
statement number two
two years ago
i became a public figure representing
domestic abuse
and i want to repeat that because you're
going to hear that throughout the case
because the timing here is critical
two years ago
i became a public figure representing
domestic abuse
statement number three
quote
i had the rare vantage point of seeing
in real time
how institutions protect men accused of
abuse
unquote
ms heard did not use mr depp's name in
the op-ed
she didn't have to
she didn't have to
because the evidence will show that
everyone in hollywood
where mr depp and miss heard both have
their careers
and many others outside hollywood
knew exactly what she was talking about
when she used the word
two years ago
i became a public figure representing
domestic abuse
that's because
as the evidence will show and you will
hear
two years earlier on may 27 2016
ms heard had publicly accused johnny
depp
her husband at the time
of domestic abuse
will learn during the trial
that miss heard's actions were prompted
by mr depp's request for a divorce
he wanted out
which drove her to concoct to make up a
story that was at first
designed to keep him
and then
when he made it clear that finally
after all he had endured he was done
was designed to recast herself
as an abuse survivor
with mr depp as the alleged abuser
the evidence will show that six days
after mr depp requested a divorce and he
did so politely
and three days after ms heard's lawyer
threatened mr depp
with claims of abuse
if he did not agree to her financial
demands ms heard arrived at the
courthouse in los angeles california to
file for a restraining order alleging
abuse
ms heard the evidence will show that ms
heard showed up with a mark on her face
that mysteriously appeared six days
after she last saw mr depp
and and six days before she publicly
filed a request for domestic violence
restraining order alleging abuse
the evidence will show
that her publicist and the paparazzi
were there at the courthouse to document
the event
to make sure that johnny depp's name
was forever associated
with the image
of an innocent battered woman
it was a jolt
it was a shocking story splashed across
front pages across the country
no one
had ever in five decades accused johnny
depp of being violent with a woman
no one had ever accused mr depp of being
violent with a woman
he had been in other long-term
relationships he had children
no one
as i stated before
no one
had ever in five decades no one had ever
accused johnny depp
of
being abusive of any kind with a woman
that's why it was such
a jolt
he had been in other long-term
relationships as i said
he had two children
and no one had even suggested ever that
he was capable of something like this
by choosing to lie about her husband for
her own personal benefit
amber heard forever changed mr depp's
life and reputation
and you will hear him tell you
the
dreadful impact that it has had on his
life
the evidence you will hear at this trial
contradicts the story ms heard presented
to the world in may 2016
and again in december 2018
the evidence will show
that the last time mr depp and ms heard
saw each other before miss heard showed
up in court on may 27 2016
was may 21st
and that's a very important date and i
will ask you please to remember that
through the trial
mr depp's mother betty sue
passed away on may 20th
after a long illness
when johnny and his sister christy had
been taking care
of of his mother for a very long period
of time
and for reasons that mr depp will
personally explain to you
throughout the course of this trial he
had resolved to divorce ms hurt
so on may 21st
mr depp came by the apartment that he
shared with miss heard in the eastern
columbia building or the ecb as some
people refer to it
to tell her that
to pick up his things
and to say goodbye
there is no dispute
that soon after mr depp ended things
with miss heard and left the apartment
on may 21st
he got on a plane to head out on a
european tour a music tour for months
with his band the hollywood vampires
and ms heard knew that he was going off
on tour and out of state when she walked
into court to get the restraining order
which she obtained ex parte it's a latin
word fancy word but all it means is that
mr depp and his lawyer were not there
and had no opportunity to be hurt
that's what an ex parte order is
you will hear from the police officers
who responded to a 9-1-1 call on may
21st
after mr depp left
the police officers will testify that
they saw
no injuries on this hurt
both police officers
will testify that they saw
no injuries on misheard
nor did the police officers see any of
the property damages that you will hear
misheard claims
existed
in the apartments that evening
and you will hear those officers under
oath
testify that there was no violence
and there was no crime
you will also hear from multiple
witnesses who
like the police officers
saw misheard between may 21 and may 26th
those are the crucial days between the
alleged incident and the day she walked
into court with her lawyer and got an ex
parte
order
and those witnesses will testify
that they saw her without any marks
any signs of injuries
on her face
and you will hear from multiple
witnesses including brandon patterson
who is the manager of the eastern
columbia building
where mr depp
and ms hurd live together
you will hear mr pat patterson say that
they that he saw and others will say as
well that they saw a surveillance video
from the week of may 21st
that showed miss hurd's sister whitney
throw
a fake punch
at miss hurt's face
let's just stop there this is a
surveillance video video you will hear
about
where
the sister of the alleged victim threw a
fake punch at her sister
allegedly
which allegedly occurred this incident
only a couple of days earlier
misheard acting out being punched
responding to the fake punch
and the two laughing about it
so you have the alleged victim
and the sister
laughing about a fake punch
and you will have to decide for yourself
or we ask that you please decide for
yourself
would anyone
ever joke
about that
if there had been actual abuse much less
ask yourself would a sister ever joke
with an alleged victim
about being punched by her husband
of course
none of this contradicting evidence was
publicly available
when ms heard walked into court on may
27 and got her restraining order
instead as you can imagine
the media storm was instantaneous
you will hear about and see some of that
media coverage which published pictures
of miss heard walking into court and
other pictures
supposedly showing injuries
supposedly caused by mr depp a man who
had never been accused
of
abuse of a woman
the evidence will show that mr depp and
miss heard
eventually settled their divorce out of
court
thereafter miss heard dismissed her
restraining order
against mr depp
but ms heard's false claim that mr depp
had abused her
remained in the public sphere it didn't
go away the images were permanent
and the
evidence will show that two years later
which is why we're pointing to that that
reference in the op-ed
in the wake of the metoo movement and
just before the release of ms heard's
role in the movie aquaman
miss heard chose to remind the world
about the festering allegations
this time under the banner of a national
international
newspaper the washington post
in the op-ed in her op-ed
ms heard again painted herself as the
innocent victim of abuse
but this time
this time with a wider audience primed
to take action
against an in industry powerhouses
accused of abuse
the evidence will show
that the clear implication
in ms herd's op-ed that you have in
front of you
was that she was the victim of domestic
abuse perpetrated by mr depp
the evidence will show that that was
a lie
and it remains a lie when it was
repeated and republished two years later
hollywood studios don't want to deal
with the public
backlash from hiring someone accused of
abuse
even someone with the incredible body of
work
and record that mr depp
can be proud of
a false allegation can devastate a
career
and it can devastate a family
and the evidence will show
that ms heard's false allegations had a
significant impact
on mr duff's family and his ability to
work
in the profession he loved
and loved to bring joy to everyone
ultimately
this trial is about clearing mr depp's
name of a terrible and false allegation
we ask you in the next several weeks to
please
please carefully consider the evidence
assess the reliability and credibility
of that evidence
and to make your own determination
about what actually happened between mr
depp and miss heard
and to tell you more about that i am
going to turn it over to my colleague
camille vasquez
who you had the pleasure of meeting
yesterday thank you all for your for
your attention
ms vasquez
you might have to turn it up a little
bit
[Music]
over the course of this trial
you're going to have an opportunity to
get to know johnny depp
not the characters he's portrayed
but the man himself
you will hear from mr depp directly
but you will also hear from his friends
his family
and employees
you will hear from people who have known
him
for decades
they have seen him at his best
and they have seen him at his worst
and they will tell you
each of them
that he is a kind soul
who has never
and would never
raise a hand to a woman
you will hear that mr depp learned at a
very young age
how to coexist with an abusive woman
you will learn from mr depp's sister
christy
and from mr death
that their mother
betty sue
lived in a constant state of anger
that would boil over daily
in vicious words
and violence
directed at her husband
and their children
and you will hear how mr depp
who had the personality of his father
coped with that abuse in the same way
his father did
he just took it
the evidence will show
that mr depp learned that the best way
to deal with violence was to leave
to get away from it
give her time to cool down
but he never turned his back on his
mother
mr depp loved his mother
and he cared for her
until the day she died
you will hear how mr depp came to los
angeles as a teenager he first planned
to be a musician
then became an actor
and eventually
thanks to his talent
his dedication
and a lot of hard work
grew into one of the biggest movie stars
in the world
he had relationships with major figures
in hollywood and elsewhere like winona
ryder
kate moss
and before he met amber heard
he was with the same woman
vanessa paradine
for 14 years
he had two children
with her
and even though he was a mega star
they had a quiet domestic life
in fact you'll hear as mr chu already
told you that mr depp's in mr depp's 58
years not a single woman has ever
accused him of violence
and nobody in hollywood or the world had
any reason to believe he was an abuser
until miss heard publicly accused him in
2016.
you're also going to hear evidence about
miss heard
you're going to learn that she's a
profoundly troubled person
who manipulates the people around her
just like she manipulated mr deb
ms hurd came to los angeles and sought a
career in acting after mr death was well
established as a movie star
mr depp and miss heard first met in 2009
on the set of the film the rum diaries
there was a significant age difference
between them and at first he avoided her
advances but she pursued him she wooed
him
the evidence will show that ms heard
went to great lengths to win him over by
playing the doting girlfriend
and it worked
he fell head over heels in love with her
those who watch this relationship
developed saw red flags all over the
place
you will hear from them in this trial
and over time the real misheard
began to emerge
she would berate him scream at him he
would try to appease her and sometimes
just sometimes things would get better
but it would always happen again
the evidence will show that mr depp
started coping with miss heard in the
same way he did as a child
he would try to get away
avoid the conflict
but he's trying to leave enraged
misheard
she would resort to physical violence
throwing things at him
hitting him
she would tell him he was a coward she
would tell him he wasn't man enough
because he wouldn't stay and fight with
her
you will see that miss heard equated
anger
and violence with passion
she would apologize with poetic excuses
as if the violence just proved how
fierce and overwhelming her love for him
was
and you're going to hear that when mr
got violent
mr depp would just retreat
just as he did with his mother
he would try to leave to get away from
her
in her words ms heard's words he would
split
mr deb would often retreat into
bathrooms lock the doors
wait out miss heard russian
but his leading just provoked her more
you will hear from mr depp's security
people like sean better about how they
often had to remove mr deb from scenes
with miss heard screaming at him chasing
him trying to keep him from leaving
you're going to hear evidence that when
mr death and mister traveled together
his team routinely had to book an extra
room
for him
so that he had somewhere to go when this
herd
became enraged
you'll hear from other witnesses
including mr depp and miss heard's
marriage counselor
her name is dr laurel anderson
who perceived miss heard as the
aggressor in the relationship
misheard as the aggressor in the
relationship
the one who would strike mr depp to try
to keep him from leaving
you'll hear from medical professionals
who were with mr depp and miss heard
often on a daily basis for years
including their doctor david kipper
and mr's personal nurse her personal
assigned nurse aaron burrem fellati
who did not see any signs of injuries
that ms heard later testified to in
graphic detail
miss heard wants you to ignore the
testimony of these medical professionals
who saw her in real time just as she
wants you to ignore the testimony of the
police officers who testified under oath
who suffer on may 21
2016
without any injuries
but it is up to you ladies and gentlemen
of this jury to judge the credibility of
these witnesses and that of misheard
in this trial misheard will undoubtedly
present photos that supposedly show
injuries she sustained as a result of
the claimed abuse by mr death
here's what you should keep in mind when
you see these photographs
first
the evidence and expert testimony from
forensic pathologist a doctor
will show that the injuries reflected in
these photographs are not consistent
with the brutal allegations of abuse ms
hurd has
alleged second
there are multiple
multiple witnesses including medical
professionals and police officers who
will testify that they did not observe
the injuries supposedly reflected in
these photographs
and you may be wondering how can that be
well you will hear expert testimony that
none of these photographs are the
originals
not one
and many are stored in an editing
program
so they could have been manipulated and
cannot be confirmed as authentic
importantly
you will not see a single photograph of
the vast majority of the abuse allegedly
misheard
not one
and there is not a single photograph or
video
showing mr depp becoming physically
violent towards his heart
the only medical report of an injury
during their relationship was a severe
one
and it was sustained by mr depp
after an argument shortly after their
marriage while the couple was in
australia
you will hear evidence that the people
who cared about mr death were
encouraging him to have a prenuptial
agreement
with miss hurt
but she rushed the wedding date and he
agreed to get married without one
after the wedding again people close to
mr deb encouraged him to consider a
post-nuptial agreement
when the topic came up ms hurd became
outraged as she always did at the
suggestion
that mr death might leave her
she berated him and when he tried to
leave she became violent
she became so violent in fact she threw
a vodka bottle at him
that hit his hand
and exploded
it severed the end of one of his fingers
you'll see pictures of mr depp's severed
finger
and learn about his emergency medical
treatment for that injury
and then you'll learn
and this is important
years later
after the false claims of abuse
that caused mr depp to file this very
lawsuit
misheard came up with an elaborate story
about what actually happened according
to her in australia
and what she said happened was that it
was a three-day hostage affair an
episode where she was violently attacked
and then
sexually assaulted by mr den
you will see for yourself that the
evidence does not support the story she
told after she was sued
you will learn that there came a time
when mr death was done
and you'll learn from him and he will
tell you why
the evidence will show that on may 20th
2016 mr depp's mother betty sue
passed away
you will hear from mr death that his
mother's passing was a wake-up call
that helped confirm what he already knew
that the relationship with ms heard
wasn't working
and that misheard was not going to
change
if you've ever lost a parent
you understand how
much this experience can change your
perspective on what is important for
your own well-being
so mr deb resolved to finally divorce ms
hurd
and told her that very day that he would
do so respectfully and most importantly
discreetly
the evidence will show that on may 21
2016
when mr depp went over to the eastern
columbia building
to gather his things
misheard caused a final dramatic scene
in the wreckage of their relationship
misheard spun the final encounter
between them into a tale of domestic
abuse
now i understand that many of you may be
asking yourselves why
why would ms heard say that mr depp
abused her during their relationship if
it didn't actually happen
why would she make up the detailed
dramatic tales of abuse that you will
surely hear in this courtroom
over the coming weeks
by the end of this trial you will have
the answer to that question
the evidence will show exactly who ms
hurd is
you will hear from mr depp and other
witnesses
including their marriage counselor dr
laurel anderson
that miss heard would go to great
lengths and even resort to physical
violence to stop mr depp from leading
her but once mr depp did leave
miss her tried to avoid public
humiliation and present herself as a
noble survivor and representative of the
metoo movement
you will hear evidence including the
testimony of miss heard's former
personal assistant kate james that miss
heard is obsessed with her public image
it's her number one priority
and you will see evidence that after she
received
a 7 million divorce settlement from mr
deb
ms heard released a public statement
claiming she wanted nothing from him
and would donate the entire settlement
to two charities
the children's hospital of los angeles
in california
and the american civil liberties union
also known as the aclu
but then
she did not make the donations
quite simply
miss heard had publicly cast herself in
the role of a domestic abuse survivor
there was no going back
when mr depp finally stood up and fought
for his good name in court by filing
this lawsuit miss her because she
couldn't back down
went
all in
after this lawsuit was filed it's
important the timeline here after this
lawsuit was filed miss heard started
making up
more and more alleged incidents of
abuse and if you'll recall ladies and
gentlemen
the headline of the op-ed
references sexual violence
but miss heard had never made that
accusation against mr death
it was never part of her allegations of
abuse
so what changed
what changed between 2016 and 2018.
we submit to you and the evidence will
show when she realized the seriousness
of what she had alleged she panicked and
she alleged sexual assault
miss heard and her lawyers are going to
tell you some truly horrific tales of
use before this trial is over
but the horrific details are designed
they're designed to shock you and to
overwhelm you
they are designed to be
explosive and they are designed to
distract you
from the evidence
and most importantly from common sense
that tells you the common sense and the
evidence will tell you that it is all a
lie
that none of this not one single alleged
incident of abuse could have happened as
miss hurt claims
miss heard's pattern is consistent
she tells the lies
then covers up that lie with still more
lies
in a constantly changing
evolving
ever more dramatic story
you're going to hear a lot about mr debt
during this trial ms hurd is going to
tell you a lot of things about him
that he abused drugs and alcohol
that he used bad and offensive language
and it's true
that mr deb has had real struggles with
substance abuse in his life he's not
denying that
you may know people close to you who
have struggled too
but struggling with drugs and alcohol
doesn't make you an abuser
he has also used some very colorful
language
he uses words that i don't use and you
probably don't use
and he uses them frequently
mr depp like all of us is not perfect
but he did not abuse misheard all of
this is just meant to distract you from
what this case is about
this case is about what ms heard said in
her op-ed
the evidence will show that miss heard
painted a picture of herself as a heroic
innocent survivor of abuse by mr depp
a beaten woman
who finally stood up to her tormentor
the evidence will show
that miss heard used her allegations
against mr depp to raise her own profile
and to advance her own career
the very same day that the op-ed was
published under the title quote
i spoke up against sexual violence end
quote
she posted that article that's now
displayed on your screens
and the title on her twitter page
right along with an announcement
that she was becoming
an aclu
ambassador on women's rights
to make sure
that quote
women and girls can live free from
violence and quote
she presented herself as the face of the
metoo movement
the virtuous representative of innocent
women across the country and the world
who have truly suffered abuse
the evidence will show
that was a lie
and the evidence will show that ms heard
betrayed mr deb as the representative of
abusers everywhere
the agent of her suffering
the villain in her heroic journey
that was a lie too
and more than just a lie it was an act
of cruelty
mr death
will go to his grave
knowing that whatever he does
there are people out there in this world
who will always believe that he
abused a woman
this is the case about what ms heard
said
it's also a case about what a man named
adam waldman said
adam waldman is a lawyer who has worked
for mr depp
after
again
after mr depp filed this case against
her
miss heard
filed her own claim against mr deb
which is also the subject of his trial
in her claim
mishrad says that mr depp defamed her
because adam waldman his attorney made
some statements to reporters denying the
truth
of her claims of abuse
adam waldman is not in this courtroom
miss heard chose not to name him in her
claim
and i won't take up too much of your
time with a discussion of her claim
against mr deb except to say a few
things
the evidence will show that those
statements weren't even made by mr death
they were made
by adam waldman and mr waldman the
evidence will show is not under mr
duff's control
the statements were merely mr boldman's
opinions
made in justified defense of his client
and friend mr depp
mr waldman believed those statements and
finally at the end of the day
mr waldman's statements
merely reflected the reality that we
intend to prove in this trial
that misheard's portrayal of herself as
a victim of domestic violence at the
hands of mr deb is a lie
misheard as you know with an actress
when she accused mr deaf abuse and
painted herself before the world as a
representative of abuse victims
everywhere miss heard took on the role
of a lifetime
she can't back down
she has been living and breathing this
lie for years now
and she has been preparing to give the
performance of her life in this
trial but this trial is about the
evidence
it's about a man's reputation
and it's about his whole life
his ability to walk down the street
look people in the eye
without having to think he's an abuser
it's about the truth
and the truth will come out in this
trial
at the end of this trial
we will ask you to render a verdict for
mr death
we will ask you to tell the world that
he is not the abuser she described
and that she is not the victim she
portrayed
and we will ask you to tell ms heard
that what she did was wrong
thank you very much
thank you miss vasquez
all right
ladies and gentlemen it's a little early
but maybe we should go ahead and take
our morning break just since it's a
natural point to have a break before we
have the second opening statement okay
so why don't we go ahead and take a
15-minute recess just remember do not
discuss the case and don't do the
outside research okay all right
all right
thank you
all right opening statements
yes mr ruttenborn
my approach yes sir
good morning everyone
my name is ben rottenborn and together
with elaine and adam i represent amber
heard
in a few minutes elaine will get up here
and she'll introduce you to amber
and she'll address the allegations that
you just heard
in mr chu and ms vasquez's opening
statement
and she'll explain to you
why all those inflammatory things
are things
that are designed to mislead you mislead
you from the truth
she'll explain to you
what the evidence will show and that's
something that we're going to focus on
in this trial
not attempts to distract you
we're going to focus on the evidence
what we wish the evidence showed
not some crazy conspiracy theories but
what the evidence and the facts actually
show
and as you assess the evidence in this
trial i would ask that you keep one
question in mind above all else which is
this
why are you here
what are you being asked to decide
you're being asked to decide a very
simple question
and that question is
were the words that amber used in the
december 18 2018 opinion piece that was
published in the washington post
protected
free speech under the first amendment or
not
that is the question and that's what
you're being asked to decide
at the end of the trial the judge will
explain to you what the law is on
defamation
and what mr depp's burden is to prove in
order to establish defamation
and she'll tell you a lot of things
about the law
but among them she'll have to she will
tell you that mr depp will have to prove
that the words misheard used were about
him and that they were false
if he can't do that and if he can't meet
the other elements of the claim then he
loses that claim
and he can't do that
he can't come close to doing that and
for that reason
you're going to hear in this trial
mr depp's team is going to make it about
trying to distract you from that very
simple question
mr depp's team is going to try to turn
this case into a soap opera
why
i'm not really sure because the evidence
isn't pretty for mr depp it's not
you're going to see who the real johnny
depp is
behind the red carpets
behind the fame behind the money behind
the pirate costumes you're going to see
who that man really is
amber is going to tell you about it
you're going to hear who he really is
from other witnesses
and you're going to hear who he really
is in his own words
in the vile graphic terrible messages
that he wrote about amber and ways he
used to describe amber and what he
wanted to do to amber
from the earliest days that they were
dating
through their marriage
and after their marriage you're going to
hear about that but this case isn't
about that
this case
isn't about a day-to-day chronicle of
their marriage
it's not about who is the better spouse
it's not about who you like more
it's not about which party can sling
more mud
but you're going to hear a lot of that
in this trial
you're going to hear that
because that's what mr depp wants to
turn this case into
he wants to turn this case into a six
week long public spectacle of the most
intimate
aspects of their relationship and their
marriage
and you know what i'm sorry for that i'm
sorry i'm sorry that we're going to have
to do that
i'm sorry that you're going to have to
lift all of it
and i'm sorry that amber's going to have
to relive that
but that's the case that johnny depp
chose to bring
and we're not going to stand idly by and
let him sling mud at our client and make
inflammatory and false statements like
you just heard an opening and not let
those go unresponded to
but ultimately
what this case is about
is about the first amendment
about that december 18 2018 op-ed piece
and whether miss heard's freedom of
speech and the first amendment
give her the right to say the words that
she said
that that right that freedom of speech
is what amber bird is asking you to
uphold and protect in this lawsuit
and that's a very simple question
the question you could decide this
afternoon
and it does not require you
to stand and serve as the umpire of two
movie stars imperfect marriage
it doesn't
and so we're going to focus on those
words
we're going to look at those words and
as we look at those words i'd ask you to
keep this in mind
keep in mind what you just saw on the
screen
for mr chu when he put up those words
keep in mind what you didn't see you
didn't see the rest of the opinion piece
and what we'd ask is that as you look at
those words
that you look at them in the context of
the piece in which they were written
now
whether you look at them individually or
in the context of the piece
doesn't really matter because the words
are true but context matters
and so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to ask
heather to put up the article put up the
opinion piece and i'm going to read that
to you
and we're going to look at those words
in the context of what this piece was
about because mr depp's team wants to
make you think that this was that this
this opinion piece was designed to
destroy johnny depp
that this was designed to maliciously
talk about him and their life together
and it wasn't
so let's take a moment to look at this
and i'm going to read it to you and
i'd ask that you follow along if you can
but either way
let's take a look at what the piece as a
whole says
this is the piece
that amber wrote
i was exposed to abuse at a very young
age
i knew certain things early on without
ever having to be told
i knew that men have the power
physically socially and financially
and that a lot of institutions support
that arrangement
i knew this long before i had the words
to articulate it and i bet you learned
it young too
like many women i had been harassed and
sexually assaulted by the time i was of
college age
but i kept quiet
i did not expect filing complaints to
bring justice
and i didn't see myself as a victim
then two years ago
i became a public figure representing
domestic abuse and i felt the full force
of our culture's wrath for women who
speak
out friends and advisors told me i would
never again work as an actress that i
would be blacklisted
a movie i was attached to recast my role
i had just shot a two-year campaign as
the face of a global fashion brand and
the company dropped me
questions arose as to whether i would be
able to keep my role of mira in the
movies justice league and aquaman
i had the rare vantage point of seeing
real time
institutions protect men accused of
abuse
imagine a powerful man as a ship like
the titanic
that ship is a huge enterprise
when it strikes an iceberg there are a
lot of people on board desperate to
patch up holes
not because they believe in or even care
about the ship but because their own
fates depend on the enterprise
in recent years the metoo movement has
taught us how about how power like this
works not just in hollywood but in all
kinds of institutions workplaces places
of worship or
simply in particular communities
in every walk of life women are
confronting these men who are bullied by
social economic and cultural power
and these institutions are beginning to
change
we are in a transformative political
moment
the president of our country has been
accused by more than a dozen women of
sexual misconduct including assault and
harassment
outrage over his statements and behavior
has energized a female-led opposition
metoo started a conversation about just
how profoundly sexual violence affects
women every area of our lives
and last month more women were elected
to congress than ever in our history
with a mandate to take women's issues
seriously
women's rage and determination to end
sexual violence are turning into a
political force
we have an opening now to bolster and
build institutions protective of women
for starters
congress can reauthorize and strengthen
the violence against women act
first passed in 1994 the act is one of
the most effective pieces of legislation
enacted to fight domestic violence and
sexual assault
it creates support systems for people
who report abuse
and provides funding for rape crisis
centers
legal assistance programs and other
critical services
it improves responses by law enforcement
and it prohibits discrimination against
lgbtq survivors
funding for the act expired in september
and has only been temporarily extended
we should continue to fight sexual
assault on college campuses while
simultaneously insisting on fair
processes for adjudicating complaints
last month
education secretary betsy devos proposed
changes to title ix rules governing the
treatment of sexual harassment and
assault in schools
while some changes would make the
process for handling complaints more
fair
others would weaken protections for
sexual assault survivors
for example
the new rules would require schools to
investigate only the most extreme
complaints
and then only when they are made to
designated officials
women on campuses already have trouble
coming forward about sexual violence
why would we allow institutions to scale
back supports
i write this as a woman who had to
change my phone number weekly because i
was getting death threats
for months i rarely left my apartment
and when i did
i was pursued by camera drones and
photographers on foot
on motorcycles and in cars
tabloid outlets that posted pictures of
me spun them in a negative light
i felt as though i was on trial in the
court of public opinion
and my life and livelihood
depended on myriad judgments far beyond
my control
i want to ensure that women who come
forward to talk about violence receive
more support
we are electing representatives who know
how deeply we care about these issues
we can work together to demand changes
to laws and rules and social norms
and to write the imbalances that have
shaped our lives
i know that was a lot
but that is the central issue in this
case
are those words
that amber wrote
are those protected by the first
amendment
and the answer is very clearly yes
so let's talk about that article for a
minute
first of all
the article doesn't mention
debt by name it never once contains his
name in that article
it is not about
amber's relationship with mr depp
there are no details of any abuse in
that article
the article is about proposed
legislation
and strengthening of government
laws and policies designed to protect
abuse victims and people who report
abuse that's what the article's about
and it was written in the midst of a
social movement
in which the american civil liberties
union the aclu
asked amber
to use her platform to speak on these
important issues
and that's what she did
to do so
she drew on her experiences as someone
who had reported domestic abuse
and there's no question there is no
dispute that she did in fact report
domestic abuse in 2016.
deppside admits that
she talked about her negative personal
experiences and her reactions and
opinions
after
being someone in hollywood who reported
abuse and the consequences that flowed
from that
she talked about what she experienced in
the days and months following reporting
that abuse
that's what the article is about
the article isn't about
johnny depp
the article is about the social change
for which she is advocating and that the
first amendment protects
and so i hope you remember as this case
goes on
that you saw
from mr chu
only the three statements in isolation
because they want you to forget that
they don't want you to pay attention to
what the article is about
now if it had been amber's intention to
use this article to detail the abuse
that she suffered
and that you'll hear about over the
course of this trial
believe me the article would have looked
very very different
she could fill a book with those details
she probably would have started out by
calling out mr depp by name
she probably wouldn't publish it in the
washington post
she would have described in great detail
the man who has described himself
the violent side of himself as the
monster
that's what she would have done
the monster
she would have told you about the
monster
but she didn't
that wasn't the point of this article
and she was careful to avoid that even
even having her lawyer review the
article to make sure
that it was okay and she relied on that
lawyer's advice and you'll hear
testimony on that during the trial
but because johnny depp brought this
case and asked for it all of that is
going to come out
just know that amber heard never wanted
to unearth for the public who the real
johnny depp is
but that's going to come out over the
course of this trial
i'd like you to also take into
consideration who isn't here today
you don't see the washington post
sitting here as a defendant in this
courtroom
depp didn't sue the washington post he
had no interest in doing that
he only sued amber
he could have sued the washington post
they published the article
but he didn't and he chose to bring
amber to court here in virginia
where she has no ties has never lived
he's never lived where they never spent
any time
because he wanted to make her life hard
he wanted to ruin her life
he wanted to destroy her
that's what he did
and
i wish i could say that that's
surprising
it's certainly disturbing but it's not
surprising
because the evidence will show that for
years
all mr def has wanted to do is humiliate
amber to haunt her
to wreck her career
that's what the evidence will show in
his words
that's what he wanted
but he made a mistake bringing this case
in virginia
because you're the people who are going
to hear this case a qualified prepared
jury
who respects the first amendment
and with that even though we've looked
at the article as a whole i'd like to
spend a few minutes looking at the
individual statements that were made
just as depth side showed you
because i think it's important to do
that as well can we pull up slide one
please
then two years ago i became a public
figure representing domestic abuse
and i felt the full force of our
culture's wrath for women who speak out
there's absolutely nothing false about
that statement
first of all the evidence will show that
amber did suffer domestic abuse at the
hands of johnny depp
and it took many forms
physical sure
but also emotional
verbal psychological abuse it's all
domestic abuse that she suffered
at his hands
so that's the truth
but what else is the truth
is that on may 27 2016
two years before this opinion piece was
published
amber walked into a courtroom in
california with bruises on her face
that were
given to her
by johnny depp on that incident in may
21st 2016 that elaine's going to tell
you more about
that absolutely were given to her and
she took out
a domestic violence restraining order
that she obtained from the court in
california to protect herself
and she was of course a public figure
she was a movie star she didn't want the
paparazzi the press photos
she got those of course
who wants to be photographed with a
bruised face walking out of court she
didn't want that and the evidence will
show that
but she was a public figure
and two years before she wrote this
article she was a public figure
representing domestic abuse that is 100
percent true
and try as he might to take it away
amber's freedom of speech gives her the
right to say that
can we pull up slide two please
this is the second statement
i had the rare vantage point of seeing
in real time how institutions protect
men accused of abuse
once again
that statement is 100 percent true
amber did accuse johnny of abuse
and she saw how he was protected at the
same time that her career
took a downturn and that he did
everything that he could to try to wreck
her career as the evidence will see
but she accused him of abuse
that statement is true you don't need to
relive every intimate detail of their
marriage you don't need to decide what
happened on any individual day of their
marriage to determine that the first
amendment protects that statement
because it is true
he wants you to forget that don't take
the bait
let's pull up the third statement please
now this statement
was in the headline
of the online edition of the article
i spoke up against sexual violence and
faced our culture's wrath that has to
change
the undisputed evidence in this case
will be that amber did not write these
words
did not review these words did not
approve these words
that's how op-eds work
she wrote the article she didn't write
this headline
and for that reason that reason alone is
not defamatory
but here's the thing like the first two
statements
tragically
it's true
amber did suffer sexual violence at the
hands of debt
and miss vasquez tried to minimize that
and tried to make you think that it's
all made up
but it's not
you will hear
in the most graphic and horrifying terms
about the violence that she suffered
you'll hear that straight from her
she will get on the stand and she will
tell you that
it happened
and by taking out that domestic violence
restraining order by obtaining that from
the court she did speak out against it
and all the other abuse that she
suffered and she said enough is enough i
need to protect myself she didn't want
to do that she didn't want to be forced
to get that restraining order but she
did
she spoke out against the abuse by doing
that
and the evidence will show that she did
face her culture's wrath perhaps
illustrated no more clearly by the fact
that she's here today
facing this lawsuit brought by an
obsessed
ex-husband hell-bent on revenge
that's why she's here that's why she's
facing our culture's wrath
and as you consider whether these
statements are true i'd ask you to keep
this in mind as well the evidence will
show that in may of 2016 when she
obtained the restraining order
mr depp never denied the allegations and
in fact he signed a statement
that amber hadn't made any false
statements for financial gain
he signed a statement saying she hadn't
made any false statements
and you'll see that in evidence in this
trial
and it was only two years later as his
career was in free fall and her career
was taking off that he pounced
that he chose to bring this lawsuit
after saying that she hadn't made false
statements
and one thing
that you'll be instructed at the end of
the trial but the mr deb side will try
to distract you from is that any damages
that he suffered and any defamation has
to flow from that 2018 opinion piece
this case isn't about the statements
made in 2016 even though they're true
this case is about the december 2018
opinion fees that's what the case is
about and i have to say
it's pretty ironic
it's pretty ironic
that a piece
that briefly discussed
amber moving on from johnny depp
that briefly discussed her life
experiences after johnny depp is the
very
vehicle that he uses to try to keep her
from moving on
to try to keep her from living that life
rather than give her her life back
rather than take personal responsibility
for his own actions
it's ironic that he uses that piece to
do that
but like i said
it's not surprising
because you will see clear and graphic
evidence of his intentions
dating back years
now in five or six weeks
elaine or i will get up here a closing
argument and we'll remind you
we'll remind you what this case is about
we'll remind you that this case is about
one piece of paper
amber's words
in this article
that wasn't about debt
wasn't about her marriage wasn't about
her relationship that it was about life
after that
it's about the freedom of speech
it's not about the soap opera that depp
will turn this case into
it's not about who you like better
it's not even about whether you agree
with the words that she wrote
it's about her right to speak them
now before i sit down i'd like to
briefly discuss
some of the damages that depp alleges in
this case because he can't win the case
if he can't show damages
and the evidence will show that he has
not suffered
one cent of damages from this op-ed
not one
now
make no mistake
johnny depp's reputation
is in tatters
his career
is in free
fall but it's because of problems that
he created
problems that he
is responsible for and he's here in
court
asking you to blame amber for them
it's not amber's fault
they're from the choices that he made
you'll hear a lot of evidence in this
trial
about those choices
you'll hear evidence of crushing drug
and alcohol abuse
you'll hear evidence of depth taking
more drugs than you can count
you'll hear evidence that before one of
the instances of abuse
a cross-country plane flight in may 2014
from boston to los angeles when he
kicked amber in the back
on a private jet
you'll hear evidence that he had had no
food for days
that he had used cocaine
that he had had half a bottle of whiskey
that he had had countless red bulls and
vodkas
that he had taken pills
and
on the plane decided to top all that off
with two bottles of champagne
you'll hear evidence of that and he
blacked out on the plane
and he abused amber
and didn't remember anything about it
when he woke up
you'll hear evidence of drug binges with
his good friend marilyn manson
you'll hear evidence of that three-day
blackout in australia that miss vasquez
tried to minimize and tell you was false
a three-day blackout
in which he abused and sexually
assaulted amber
all because she had the courage to
confront him about his drinking
imagine that
a concerned spouse confronts her husband
about his drinking and gets rewarded
with that
that is what the evidence will show that
is what happened to my client
that three-day blackout
that led her to be so in fear for her
life that she barricaded herself in her
room
that same three-day blackout
that kept him from being able to do what
he was in australia to do
which was to film pirates of the
caribbean five
his behavior on that trip both before
the blackout and during it kept him from
being a reliable actor
he showed up late to the set
and after that blackout
he was gone from the set for a long time
now he did cut off his finger but the
evidence will show
my client did not do it
and just imagine this what ms vasquez is
trying to get you to buy is that
heard somehow developed a major league
level fastball and cut off his finger
with a bottle
you'll see the evidence
you'll see that that doesn't make any
sense and you'll hear from miss herds
experts who testify including orthopedic
hand specialists who testify there was
no way that that happened
you'll also
see pictures
of what mr depp
did after he cut off his finger when he
dipped it in blood and paint and wrote
graffiti all around the house that's
what you're going to see he did
and you're going to ask yourself how can
someone
that is blacked out how can they deny
that they abuse someone how can they
deny
what they were told that they did
he has no credibility when he gets up
here now in this court and tells you he
didn't do this or do that when he was
blacked out
so just remember that
those were problems that he created
you'll hear evidence that the same
addictions that led him to abuse amber
also led to the demise of his career as
an actor
like i said
as you saw with disney as you the
evidence will show with disney
he was unreliable as an actor and those
same self-destructive tendencies led to
financial distress
quite simply he was running out of money
and that distress
fueled his abusive tendencies toward
amber
and it led the public to think less and
less of him
and you will see a parade of witnesses
who testify
in johnny's case
that all have one thing in common
they all rely on him
they're all on his payroll
for the most part
or they rely on him for some sort of
luxury in their life
and you'll see that of these witnesses
so in a lot of ways
amber previewed the parade of witnesses
when she said in her op-ed and i'm going
to read from it
and quote it here she said you remember
when i said this
imagine a powerful man as a ship like
the titanic
that ship is a huge enterprise
when it strikes an iceberg there are a
lot of people on board desperate to
patch up holes
not because they believe in or even care
about the ship but because their own
fates depend on the enterprise
remember that
as depths witnesses take the stand none
of whom know what happened behind closed
doors between him and amber none of whom
can testify to that
but remember that these are people who
care about their own financial
well-being just as they previewed in
that article
and they know what happens to people who
stand up to depp they know what happens
because they've seen it
they've seen it with amber
and they've seen it with other people in
his life who had the courage to ask him
to change
and who we lashed out against
these are people who helped enable the
man who describes himself as the monster
make no mistake
this man's poor choices
have brought him to this courtroom
his own bad behavior
his own refusal to commit to sobriety
his own violence
his poor choices
and the people who have spoken up
against it
they've they're the ones that have
suffered the consequences
you'll hear evidence that he fired his
longtime agent
that he got rid of his business managers
and his law firms that had represented
him for years
and no one has suffered
from his refusal to take accountability
more than ever heard
you'll hear evidence that two years
before the op-ed
two years before that
mr debt brought someone else into his
life who helped convince him to blame
other people
that man
adam waldman
who miss vasquez introduced you
had never met mr depp while he was in a
relationship with miss heard
or while he was represented by his
agents or his
former business managers
but he convinced him
that all these bad things that are
happening happening in his life he
helped convince him of this were other
people's fault
and you'll hear evidence of that
rather than take responsibility for
cleaning himself up
that chose to blame other people that's
why we're here and the evidence will
show you crystal clearly
that the op-ed
had nothing to do with damages that he
suffered
he's going to try to make it sound like
this caused him to lose pirates of the
caribbean six that which had is a movie
that hasn't been made but that disney
wasn't going to cast a minute because of
inker's article but there's no evidence
of that
the evidence will actually show that
months before the op-ed it was reported
that disney was considering dropping him
from pirate six
the evidence will show that disney had a
dossier on him that had articles from
the press had other information about mr
depp and they didn't have this article
at all in their files
didn't register with them
just as it didn't register with the
public
the public had known since 2016
what amber had to say about johnny depp
this didn't change any of that
the evidence will also show
that he said he would not make pirate
six even if disney paid him far more
money than he never made on a film
that's what the evidence will show
so any damages that he suffered in his
career are not because of this op-ed
and it's time
to make johnny take
responsibility
to tell him mr depp stop blaming other
people for your self-created problems
to take responsibility for your own life
and it's up to you ladies and gentlemen
to make him do that
it's up to you
because you are uniquely qualified to do
that
no one else has the power to do that
only you
to tell him enough is enough
to stand up for the first amendment
to stand up for the truth
and amber's right to speak it
thank you
right thank you mr rottenborn
uh miss brudderhoff
yes
okay
good morning still
it's good to see you all again and thank
you again very much
ben told you we will be relying on the
evidence rather than the hyperbole and
the personal attacks and he was right
the evidence in this case simply put is
overwhelming and compelling
in the six weeks we're going to try to
show you as much as we possibly can
there are many many many photographs now
you heard ms vasquez try to say oh you
can't trust those it's not the originals
she's got that wrong it's not from the
original devices
ms heard took all kinds of photographs
and her friends took photographs and all
of those remained on the cloud and all
of them have been imaged and all of them
have been examined by their i.t experts
and they cannot discredit one photograph
then she says oh and it's it's got a
photo editing thing well all iphones
have the photo editing it's where you
can make it a little lighter or darker
you can move it to the center or not
that doesn't discredit the photographs
and we will have an i.t expert who will
testify that all of these are legitimate
authentic photographs not only that but
ms heard produced all of her different
devices over the years including her
most recent laptop and they were pulled
from many many sources and all of them
are identical so if she was going to go
in and try to manipulate she would have
had to do it everywhere and miss heard
will tell you she doesn't have that
level of talent there may be a couple of
you on the on the jury who have that
talent she does not have that talent
they're all very legitimate photographs
and listen carefully to the evidence
from the experts and you will find every
single piece is authenticated and is
true and they show bruises and they show
cut lips they show hair pulled out of
her hair they pull they show all kinds
they show two black eyes when you head
butted her those are all going to be
there we also are going to show you a
video and i'll talk about the time frame
of it ms heard took that on her ipad um
and it was one day when she was in the
build the kitchen with mr depp and it
was february 10 2016 and he's on a tear
and he's going around he's yelling at
her and being abusive to her and he's
slamming the kitchen cupboards and their
glass and you can hear them rattling and
you can hear them breaking then he goes
over with a big glass of wine and he has
a huge bottle of wine and he pours more
in there and then she says did you drink
all of that and then he sees that he's
she's videotaping him and
bam that's going to be a pretty graphic
one for you to see then you're going to
hear audio tapes which are pretty
significant too ben told you about the
may
2014 plane boston plane incident we call
it where he kicked her where he was so
drunk and he blacked out
well amber audio taped him when he went
to the back of the plane and passed out
and was moaning loudly
you will hear that you will also hear
some other audio tapes that are very
significant one of them in australia at
the end of the three-day hostage
situation you will hear apparently mr
depp turned on ms heard's iphone she was
never allowed to have a password by the
way he would never let her do that
during their relationship but he must
have inadvertently turned it on there's
five hours of audio tape it's during the
cleanup of all the broken glass and the
liquor and the urine and the bloodstains
and everything else in that house and
you can hear his handlers talking about
it you can hear them talking about
trying to find his finger
and that you can hear them say she's
stone cold sober you will hear all of
that it's very very significant evidence
what this is going to tell you is the
story of a very different johnny depp
it's one who is
always uh always well i can't say always
because he has the current
charismatic side that amber fell in love
with but he has an enormous amount of
rage you will see the medical records
and hear from the psychiatrist that
talked to him for a while in 2014 where
he admits that he has rage that he's
like a demon that he views his his wife
amber like his mother and his sister
that he hates
um that's that's what you will see you
will see that and it'll be fueled by the
alcohol and the drugs ben told you a
little bit about that you're going to
see a list of his prescription drugs
that his concierge doctor and team who
charge him a hundred thousand dollars a
month and have since 2014 and they are
still his concierge doctors that's the
list of the medications he takes in one
day that they prescribe that doesn't
include the cocaine it doesn't include
the ecstasy the mdma the mushrooms and
all of the others
now
it's during these rages that mr depp
engaged in verbal emotional physical and
sexual abuse of amber
let me introduce you to amber the
lesser-known person here and i know when
we were doing the voideer none of you
had even watched as much as three of her
movies so i'm going to tell you a little
bit about amber she's 35 years old she's
from austin texas she grew up outside of
austin texas she has a daughter una who
turned one last week
amber grew up in in a
area her father was a construction
worker primarily a painter but he would
break horses as part-time they lived out
on a ranch area
her mother paige who died it two years
ago at age 63 dropped out of medical
school to marry amber's father
she worked for the state of texas in
internet communications
they grew up very poor amber has a
sister whitney who's 16 months younger
than her
and you will see and hear from whitney
later because unfortunately she also
witnessed some of the abuse
amber rode horses with her father she
tried to work with him to help him break
the horses she remembers having a broken
arm at least four times being in casts
during that time but there were some
things she learned from breaking those
horses that was very significant her
father taught her she couldn't show fear
she couldn't show pain and she couldn't
show emotion
that's how she could break those horses
it's significant for you to know that so
you can understand how amber could have
remained in this relationship with mr
depp for as long as she could and the
dynamics of some of the abuse you're
going to hear about because that's what
would be her instinct is to stand up and
not let him
show that he's caused the pain that he
should cause the fear that he's caused
the humiliation
you'll hear about a long line of jobs
that amber started from back you know
age 12 as soon as she could working in a
soup kitchen well that was volunteer but
then she took all kinds of miscellaneous
jobs lifeguards everything else trying
to improve herself she's not somebody
who had a great break
what happened was she got recognized by
a hollywood agent who expressed some
interest in her she took her 180 dollars
that she'd saved up and she went to la
that's all she had to her name
the testimony would be she worked all
kinds of different jobs when she was in
l.a anything that she could get and she
would go on but she didn't have a
vehicle so she would go on buses and
she'd go up to six six different
auditions in one day she'd have a map
and she'd have in the bust and then she
would just go around she had a big
sweater so she could change underneath
it to whatever the role was so that she
could get things and she wasn't going
for you know famous actor roles she was
taking one-liners she was taking extras
she was doing anything she could to make
money to survive and then you know what
she did with it she gave a bunch of it
back to her parents she started helping
support them then when whitney graduated
from high school she brought her out to
la and and put a house roof over her
house and put her through community
college she took care of her family with
what she made
when she met johnny depp in 2009 when he
hired her for rum diaries to star across
from him she felt like she was pretty
successful she'd starred in some roles
she had a she had an apartment she had a
vehicle a mustang she could go to
starbucks she could afford starbucks she
viewed herself as doing pretty well at
that point
now during the rum diaries she
she got to know mr deb not true that she
was pursuing him or anything else she
was in the long-term relationship with
tasha van ray and he was in a long-term
relationship with vanessa parody neither
of them had any kind of romantic
relationship at that time
when she departed from 2000 from from
the rum diaries in 2009 johnny started
pursuing her
in fact he sent her a number of gifts
one of them was a guitar and she
returned it
now two years later fast forward that's
when the press
junket started and that's when she had
to come back and meet with him and they
ran on the press tours at that point she
had ended the relationship with tasha
van reeve and he said he had ended his
relationship with vanessa parody so
during the press trips that's when they
started dating and by both accounts felt
madly in love she loved the side of
johnny that we see in the movies the
charismatic one the charming one the
generous one that's the man she fell in
love with but sadly the monster came in
the way
and that monster would come out when he
was drinking and and when he would take
the drugs
amber will never forget the first event
of abuse
she was sitting in his house in sweet
sir on the sofa and he was across from
her and they were talking about a tattoo
that he had that had
had winona winona ryder forever he had
altered that to wine forever after he
broke up with winona ryder just an aside
he had slim which was his nickname for
amber when they broke up he turned into
scum but in any event he had that on
there and amber thought he was making a
joke when he was talking about it and
she laughed
and he haven't slapped her now you see
the rings that mr depp has on hertz when
he slaps
and she was stunned
she had no idea what to think
and she kind of laughed thinking well
maybe that was a joke
what just happened and he slapped her
again and then she just froze
and just looked
and then he hit her again and this time
it knocked her right off the sofa under
the ground and she remembers
her face was in this dirty filthy carpet
that's what she remembers and fixated on
the dirty carpet and she's thinking
oh my god i have to leave
i have to leave
but i love him
i have to leave but i love him
and she sat there for the longest time
she laid there for the longest time then
johnny came off the sofa got on his
knees
started crying
told her he was very very sorry that he
had done this it would never happen
again and he said some very significant
words
i thought i had put the monster away for
good
that's what he said to her that day
well amber ended up leaving that day and
she went out to her car her mustang and
she remembers that it was cold and she
sat in the car for the longest time and
she remembers watching her breath
because it was cold and she was thinking
i have to leave him but i love him she
just kept thinking that
she finally drove away
but amber made the mistake that millions
before her and millions after her have
who are victims of domestic abuse
she chose to stay
and try to fix the problem
and thinking that she could do that
so she stayed now amber was also she
grew up in an abusive family her father
abused her mother and sometimes she and
whitney so she had that cycle in there
just as you've heard that johnny had
that cycle in his house and so what's
the normal to them is a little bit more
difficult for than some of us can
understand you will hear
witness expert witness testimony about
the cycles of violence
and what happens with these people
and how they react and and all the
dynamics of thinking they can fix them
she thought
all the way through she could fix them
if she can just get him sober and clean
then everything was going to be that
wonderful side that she fell madly in
love with and she kept trying and she
kept trying she went to al-anon meetings
she went to therapists she tried to do
couples therapy you'll you'll hear about
their tape recording sessions to try to
resolve fights or de-escalate them so he
wouldn't get mad at her for anything um
but you'll hear that he gets mad at her
for all kinds of things but he got he
didn't want her to work here she's a
budding actor who wants to be out there
and succeed and he doesn't want her to
take roles he starts controlling what
she wears he starts looking at her lines
when she tries out for places he nixes
any any romance scenes sex scenes he
gets mad and accuses her of sleeping
with every single one of her co-stars
it became a cycle of that a control as
well emotional abuse as you go
but what's also significant in that is
the property damage
and that's a hard one for mr deb to be
able to escape when he's clam claiming
that he's such a docile thing and that
it's all misheard
you're gonna see pictures he writes on
mirrors horrible things to her write
some lamp shades uh you know
on clothing on countertops in australia
when you heard ben talk about australia
he wrote
the third day as amber comes out after
she's barricaded herself and gone
through a lot and i'll back up on that
in a minute she comes out he's got
mashed potatoes spread across the top
he's got he's written along the wall of
the staircase going down
all kinds of nasty things about her and
billy bob thornton the last one she was
in a co-star with and you know [ __ ]
ambition and all kinds of things like
that then he's written on the lampshades
downstairs and then he's got more on the
mirrors
and then on top of it you've got all the
broken glass everywhere and you've got
the liquor everywhere
and it's it's just
and then he's urinated tried to urinate
messages to her that's the johnny depp
that's the other side
now you're going to hear that amber
tried to protect hill all the way
through she didn't want the public to
know this she didn't want his kids to
know this and so she didn't tell people
about it
so let's go back the first event that i
told you about was 2011 and how do we
know that it was in 2011 because amber
was going through her therapist bonnie
jacobs and bonnie jacobs has therapy
notes of of her sessions with amber and
in those therapy notes she
chronicles the first time that amber
tells her that johnny hit her and it
goes through into 2012
2013 2014 and you will see and you will
hear from bonnie jacobs her saying
you know this is a cycle of violence
this is a cycle of use you you can't
enable him you need to you need to stand
up for yourself amber will testify about
how johnny would get so drunk and so
drugged out that he would vomit all over
himself and worse lose control of his
bowels she would clean him up
and and you'll see bonnie jacobs and
these notes saying don't do that you're
enabling him don't do it leave him there
but what would happen was his handlers
would then take care of him if she left
him
so that's the story you're going to hear
on that let me just tell you about a few
of the events and i'm going to start in
australia that's the three day hostage
she gets there now you will hear mr deb
testify under oath that for 15 to 18
months before the march 2015 australia
event when he's there filming
that that he's been sober clean and
sober
then you'll see all the text messages
for the last 18 months in which he's
scoring drugs in which you'll hear
testimony from people in which he's
gotten drunk and and and you know taking
all kinds of different drugs
the whole time he doesn't get clean and
sober
but he claims that he was clean and
sober that she came there she this is a
month after they just got married she
flew in from filming the danish girls
she's there and he claims that he was
just sitting there calmly and he just
and she was haranguing him so he took a
shot
glass of vodka and when she did when he
did that she got mad took the bottle of
vodka was eight to ten feet about where
i am from you and hurled it at him and
it happened to just take off the bottom
part of his finger
and then he says she came and burned a
hole in his in his cheek
the testimony is going to be that he
self-mutilated on a number of occasions
and burned himself from the cheek and
also cut himself but amber never did
that and you're going to hear from the
experts testifying about this finger
injury and how fantastic this version is
but the other part of it was he was with
marilyn manson for the week before
scoring on cocaine you'll have you'll
see text messages of him getting it from
his handlers the cocaine and the liquor
and you'll hear so much before that but
amber gets there and instead what he
does is he takes eight to ten tablets of
ecstasy almost immediately and the next
three days are just a cycle of of a very
very very violent uh uh activity by him
amber keeps trying to calm him down she
tries to get him to eat she tries to get
him to sleep she tries to do these
things and he would just at different he
was you know at times delusional
paranoid he would be you know mad at
somebody else then he'd be mad at her
and by the way we'll talk about the
prenup but he called her lawyer who she
had because she wanted to give him a
prenup and then they got married too
quickly so she was going to give him a
post-nup he called the lawyer from
australia
called her a [ __ ] and fired her
you'll hear the testimony from the
lawyer on that um that's the type of
johnny depp that was there he didn't
want the post nap he didn't want the
premium but now they're going to tell
you that's that that it was her that was
mad you're gonna hear she had a lawyer
and she was cooperating completely on
that
so as you go through those three days of
australia some pretty horrendous things
happen to her he rips off her nightgown
he has her jammed up against
a bar he has hurled bottles and bottles
at her she has dragged her across the
floor on the broken bottles in the
liquor he has punched her he has kicked
her he tells her he's going to [ __ ]
kill her he [ __ ] hates her he's
pounding at her pounding her and then he
penetrates her with a liquor bottle
that's the johnny depp that you're going
to hear about in this case
now after that amber goes to the airport
what does she do
she buys a book by a by a psychiatrist
who's talking about couples therapy
she's already trying to figure out a way
to fix it again fix this marriage that's
only a month old and her husband has
just done these horrible things to her
now they go back to
to uh l.a he's got to get his finger
fixed so he has to stop filming pirates
5. they get there and there's another
fight in just two weeks from there he's
still using at this point he's still
drunk but amber finds uh on a tv screen
his monitor she finds pictures of
another woman naked pictures of a woman
and text messages which show that he's
clearly having an affair
she gets extremely mad uh average yeah
can be jealous too she can get angry you
know she's half his age and you know she
she's you know defiant and we're not
going to say she's perfect she was mad
as can be when she saw that and she
confronted him the two of them were
screaming at each other now her sister
whitney happened to be in the house she
was summoned she literally was awakened
to come and try to resolve this fight
between the two of them
while she's there johnny starts hitting
amber um and
whitney ends up getting in between them
and amber thinks that johnny's going to
throw her down push her down the stairs
because he's in that position so amber
actually gets up and punches johnny in
the face she'll tell you that's the only
time she has ever laid one on him you
know in
an aggressive manner but it's after he's
already been hitting her and it's in
defense of her sister and she'll admit
she got him that time and she actually
did have an impact on him she'll testify
about how many times they were in their
fights and she said you know she's
almost half his size so he you know she
said if i pushed him he doesn't move he
pushes me i go flying across the room
there isn't any you know
ability on her part to be the abuser
what she'll also tell you is it took her
a while to ever fight back that
many times before that she would do what
she did when she was breaking the horses
she wouldn't show fear she wouldn't show
pain she would look at him she would
just be defiant and all it would do is
piss him off more she'll tell you that
she tried everything she tried
everything you know from trying to be
nice trying to get away from him you
know she would throw things in his way
to get him from running after her she
would she would try to you know flail
back she would use her hands and legs
and she would go and try to fight him
she'd run into a room and try to
barricade and push his hands and
everything out of there she'd try all
those things but she couldn't figure out
what could get him to calm down
i'm going to fast forward now to the
next one and that is
i'm going to jump you up to
after the stare incident and johnny had
to get surgery on his finger that's the
longest period of time he stayed sober
it was almost three months you're going
to hear that he has never been through
rehab even though he has been a lifelong
drug addict and alcoholic never has he
gone through a rehab plan instead
there's twice that he went to some new
york hospital and did a cleansing one
time it was for three days and one day
one time it was for five days and that's
it he's never made any effort whatsoever
to get sober or or stop the drugs but
this particular time he did for almost
three months and you'll see the text
messages we're going to take you through
this whole story and all the text
messages and all the emails and all the
testimony that you're going to get
so fast forward to december 2015 that
was one of the worst
australia was pretty bad but this one
was even worse in this particular
occasion he gets angry for some reason
and he starts dragging her by her hair
through the apartment
kicking her punching her
tearing her hair out at one point she
gets up and looks at him and he head
butts her and she gets two black eyes
from it then he goes and grabs drags her
up the stairs puts her on the bed puts
his foot and knee in the back of her and
he continues to punch her telling her
he's [ __ ] hating her and he's [ __ ]
gonna kill her and he's got his boot
stuck in the the bed frame as he's doing
it and the force of what he's doing to
her causes the bed frame to splinter
that's how much force she is suffocating
in the pillow and she's she believes
truly she's going to die on this one she
wakes up to her friend being there she
doesn't know how long that she was
unconscious or subconscious she doesn't
know but johnny was gone at that point
and her friend saying are you okay are
you okay you'll see the pictures of all
of this you'll see the pictures of the
hair imagine how much that must hurt but
the hair that's out on the ground and
you'll see the pictures of amber now
here's the ironic thing the next day
she's got got to be on the james corden
show and you can see the text messages
she's not sure if she can go she's
worried she's got two black eyes she's
got a split lip she's got bruising she's
got her hair missing but her friends
rally with her she's got a makeup artist
you can hear from melania glacis who
does the best
job of makeup you could imagine to get
her through the james corden show and
she does it but you'll see the pictures
the before and you'll see them then and
that that's the resilient amber who says
i'm going to go do this anyway now her
friends she tells i you're going to hear
about io till it write
he was in new york she texted him and
said johnny beat me up really good this
time
can you help and he says i i was filming
something i stopped i got the first
flight out of there i'm flying from new
york back to l.a i see her on the james
corden show i can see the swelling
because i know her well i can see the
swelling
and then he said somebody touched her
and she flinched on the show
he said that's not like amber he got
there they hadn't cleaned up all the
mess he sees the hair he sees the
splinter he sees all of the other things
and he is so upset he was a good friend
of johnny's as well he'll testify about
all of his friendship with johnny but he
put his foot down on that one and said
you need to have consequences you cannot
do this to amber anymore i am not your
friend anymore
now there were several people that were
supposed to go to johnny's island
bahamas island on in december for
christmas he was going to bring his two
kids he'd invited amber's parents um who
loved johnny and unfortunately her
father used to drink and he'd do drugs
with johnny a lot
and he was also going to take rocky her
friend who lived next door in a
penthouse and her fiance and rocky's
parents imagine being able to go to a
bahamas island for christmas what a cool
thing to do
but they all were so upset what he did
to amber on december 15 they said no
we're not going we're not gonna we're
not gonna condone this we're not going
but he talked amber into going he
guilted her into going i'm going to be
with my kids please come i'll be better
i'm going to get better amber went
and then he ends up assaulting her even
there and sexually assaults her even
there now you'll see a video from them
of the bahamas
the bahamas the place that they stayed
in on his island
and the video just conveniently leaves
out the wardrobe in the bathroom where
he committed the assault it just goes
around and makes it look like it's one
room and his kids were there and there's
no way they could have done that but but
you'll hear the testimony and you'll see
the pictures
then from then on things really were bad
for amber and she was really considering
leaving him at this point and she was
talking to her friends and confiding
you'll see you know the medical medical
records
and
in february 2016
i told you you'll see that video
that same night before the video he
called io till it right and left him a
voicemail message that he said was just
absolutely delusional it was crazy he
was pretending like he was the property
management uh it was just an insane call
and then the next day we have the
picture of the video
then we get to april 30th of april 21st
2016. amber's 30th birthday party she
was going to turn 30 the next day
pretty big event her friends had a tape
that they put together of everybody
giving her tributes johnny doesn't
participate they have a dinner and a
party for her that night johnny says i
have a business meeting at 7 00 p.m
i'll be there after that what kind of
business meeting do you need to have at
7 pm when your wife turns 30
but he that's that's johnny right um and
he can't say that it was an important
financial one because he'd fired his
financial manager the month before when
as you heard from ben it was blaming him
for all his financial problems so he's
the he's the problem
so he shows up late drunk drugs
and after everybody and he's even
drinking while he's there and he's
telling the other friends and you'll
hear from one of them that he's saying
hi here hide the bible from amber hide
the bible from amber when they all leave
she expresses her disappointment he gets
mad and assaults her again including
sexually assaults her
then he goes away and he doesn't come
back for a month now this is an
important event may 21 2016. this is the
last one and this is the final straw
that leads out to the dvtro the domestic
violence temporary restraining order
so he says he's coming over to get some
clothes he's going to go out on tour she
says okay he comes over
and he's
his mother died the day before
and he's already in the state he's been
drinking he's clearly high and he comes
in and he's got on his mind
this
obsession
that when she on her birthday go back to
her birthday the next day she and her
friends went to coachella but his
housekeeper had come in to clean after
that always did um and the housekeeper
found
some
you know feces on the bed um and had
been upset about it and taken a picture
and sent it to him so all of a sudden a
month later he's got it in his head
that amber has conspired with her
friends
to
defecate on the bed it's human not dog
even though they got two dogs and one of
them has major problems you'll hear
about boo and pistol um and and somehow
amber was doing this so he would get
back there and find it even though he
had no intention of coming back and even
though the housekeeper was there and he
he won't lose it he won't get rid of it
he's just obsessed with it then he
decides that it's i o till it right
who did it even though i wasn't at the
birthday party and wasn't even in town
so amber gets io on the phone io's in
new york and she says this is what
johnny says can you please just calm
them down tell them this isn't true tell
them we didn't do it we don't have a
conspiracy here
and i was thinking what
and you'll hear from io he'll say
amber's fecal phobia i mean she can't
even you know she she's so embarrassed
about that stuff she would never
conspire never do anything like that to
him so they're kind of laughing at the
absurdity of it and that was the biggest
mistake because that triggered his anger
and then he he started after started
hitting amber he took her grabbed the
cell phone from her wound it up and
bashed it into her face and you will see
the pictures you will see the bruise
there and you'll see the form of it
there
now i was very very upset he's worried
because he knows about the december 15
2015 and he says he says amber get out
of there get out of there you know are
you safe you know get it get out of
there you know as as johnny's storming
around um and he calls rocky who lives
next door uh and then he calls 9-1-1 and
it's that clear you know whether amber
said call 9-1-1 or he said call 991 but
they call he calls 9-1-1 but he's in new
york and he's genuinely concerned for
her safety so he calls 9-1-1 there he
calls a friend in la and says please
call 9-1-1 and just tell them this so
they get somebody there so we can get
somebody fast i don't know what's going
on
so
the police are called twice
essentially and now here's what happens
next johnny goes around and he trashes
the apartment before he leaves he loves
to do that you're going to hear about
his pension for that does it a lot
and you'll see a picture of him in the
elevator afterwards leaving with his
bodyguards and he's a little agitated
there
and the police are called you will see
pictures of amber with metadata on them
both before during and after the police
officers are there but what happens is
amber calls her attorney the one that
she had consulted after the december 15
event and the attorney says if you press
charges they'll arrest him
and amber says i can't have that happen
i don't want his kids to know about this
i don't want the public to know i can't
have that happen so when the police show
up
she refuses to cooperate she says on the
advice of my attorney i'm not going to
cooperate
but her friend
rocky whose fiance was there josh at
this point
he takes them around and shows one of
the police officers all the property
damage around the house as well and the
police officers say to him look she's
got the red mark on there you know if
you just give us the name we'll we'll go
get him and he says i can't she won't
let me
so they leave now here's what happens
and creates all of the you know noise
here that you're going to have to deal
with so the police officers don't make
an incident report they don't take a
report they don't document the property
damage they don't document the facial
damage instead
they go out and they write on their cad
that's their little system in there they
write verbal dispute only victim
uncooperative
that's their language for we don't have
to write a report you'll see that the
police officers have another one later
that night another and they put verbal
dispute only that's their magic language
now that's notwithstanding that you will
see these pictures but amber wasn't
cooperating with them and they were
quite convinced she wasn't going to so
as many domestic violence you know calls
that they take
they're not gonna you know they're not
gonna this is one that they they figure
it's it's it's gone now the other police
officers come two hours later they've
cleaned up the place at this point they
don't know that these police officers
are arriving but when they do arrive
there they try to discourage them even
from coming in josh answers the door
says no the other lawyers are the other
police officers were already here
and he says and they say no but we just
have to see her and they have body cams
by the way so you'll see the body cam
footage of this
they go through and they do that and um
and one of the significant things is
you'll see on the cad that that the two
police officers sets are communicating
with each other and that first set says
i don't think she's going to change her
mind
and they they know who the officers were
the first time because they say officer
signs you'll hear hear this and you'll
see it in the body cam footage
so they go through amber says no
everything's fine you can see on there
and they leave
now the reason this is so significant is
what they have done with this in
creating and that's part of the counter
claim and what what their and their
version of the reality is is that the
amber calls the clock the cops then they
don't see any injury
so they mess up the place splash a
little wine and then call another set of
cops
does that sound like the situation here
no no and it's really important to look
at the evidence and think about this
you'll hear from many actually i don't
know how many of the police officers
will put on but we have you know between
four and six lapd police officers and
experts who will say those police
officers even when she declined to
cooperate should have taken a report
they should have documented it that was
police policy
so
when faced with this big public
you know
big public dvro and all of the publicity
later now they go back to the police
officers and say hey wait a second you
didn't take a report you said it was a
verbal dispute only
they're stuck
you know if all of that was true and
they admitted it was true then they
violated policy by not doing the report
because they were supposed to take a
report
so the police officers chose the other
and said no there was no evidence
but you're going to watch it you're
going to see it in real time you're
going to see it on metadata
so amber goes to get the dv the the
domestic violence tro you're going to
see the letter that her lawyer wrote to
johnny depp's lawyer that week telling
them that that's what she would have to
she was going to do
if
but but giving them opportunity here to
be able to resolve it to get a mediator
you know just make sure that she's safe
that she can stay in the residence until
they figure things out that she can
drive her vehicle until they figure it
out you know some attorney's fees
whatever you're going to see the letter
and you're so they knew and it says
right in there she's going to go in on
friday they chose not to go they keep
saying ex-parte but they chose not to
appear and they knew she was going to
appear well amber didn't call tmz but
somebody called tmz to take all those
photos that day
now you also heard them say that all
kinds of people saw amber that week and
she didn't
she didn't have any bruises on her face
well let me show you this
this is what amber carried in her purse
for the entire relationship with johnny
depp
she's an actor do you honestly think she
would have left her apartment ever
without makeup do you think that she
ever would have wanted other people to
see her bruises and her cuts
this
was what she used she became very adept
at it and you're going to hear the
testimony from amber about how she had
to mix the different colors for the
different days of the bruises
as they were as they developed in the
different coloring and how she would use
these to touch those up to be able to
cover those she also used concealer
foundation you'll hear from a makeup
person that amber didn't even leave her
bedroom without having foundation on and
one of the people that was at the
building testified he said she had
makeup on and it would have covered that
purpose
so that's that's the testimony on that
now
let me talk about the divorce just for a
moment
so they go through they have the two
months of trying to resolve the divorce
ben already told you that they signed a
joint statement in which mr depp admits
that she did not make any of these
allegations
falsely and not for financial gain
but they brought up the donation so i
want to talk to you about the donations
for a moment
now
here's the story amber didn't have a
prenup she didn't have a post now she
was more than willing to do that but as
i told you mr depp fired her lawyers and
said only till death
that's the only way we're going to part
is through death we're not we don't need
a post net we don't need a prenup that's
johnny it's true his advisors were all
telling him get one and she said i'll
get one and she hired a lawyer but
anyway she didn't have a prenup so what
you're gonna hear is that meant no
matter what whether it was abuse
adultery
irreconcilable differences abandonment
doesn't matter she's entitled to 50
of everything during that marriage well
he did pirates five and he did two other
movies during that time and you'll see
that he made 65 million dollars during
those two years half of that is 32.5
amber didn't want that
you'll see a letter you'll see an email
from her lawyer that she forwarded on to
her agent who became johnny's agent
later saying um i want you to sign this
because you're entitled to a whole lot
more than 7 million um and i don't want
you to come basically i don't want you
to come back and sue me for malpractice
um that's what her lawyer tells her
and then her lawyer says i offered them
even less than they i i demanded less
than they offered in other words the 7
million was less than mr depp's team was
even offering to her
and she said i just want to be left
alone i just want to get out of this
marriage i don't want it i'm not doing
this for financial okay so she didn't
take the money so she said i'm going to
donate all seven million of this to
charity half to aclu half to children's
hospital
and and then what happened was the fir
and by the way the seven million was
paid out over time it's installments it
was over you know you'll see you'll see
the documents but it's over a couple of
years right
so her his business manager ed wayne
you'll see the letters he sends the
first hundred thousand out of the seven
million to each of them
and says this is a pledge
towards the 3.5 million that amber's
donating and she'll be paying that in
installments so everybody knows she's
paying it in installments you're going
to hear differently from them now but
you're going to see that was the
admission at the beginning you're going
to hear from children's hospital and the
aclu that they assumed this was a pledge
paid over a period of time because
that's what they do because of tax
deductions and things of that nature
so amber does make she makes a 250 000
payment to children's hospital then she
also makes a 250 000 payment to art of
elysium which is another charity that
she worked for um
and
used to feed and used to do a lot of
arts work with the children's hospital
she pays 350 000 to the aclu
now in addition to that she also was
dating elon musk by this time you'll
find out that mr dev is obsessed with
elon musk but she's dating him so he
gives 500 000 to both of those charities
in her honor now she doesn't claim
that's part of the 7 million but what
happens is that she gets she makes her
payments up through 2018
mr depp sues her march 1 2019 in this
litigation
she can't afford right now to be making
those pledges she's got to defend
herself
but she has every intention of
continuing to make those payments she
has been a lifelong person who has
served charities she she used to
volunteer at children's hospital three
times a week when she could she's very
much that kind of person and she intends
to and both both aclu and children's
hospital will tell you they have no
reason to believe she won't be good on
her pledges there's nothing that
required her to do a certain amount at a
certain time and she will give it to him
once she's able to afford it again
now let me talk about the counter plan
for a minute
and then i'm gonna i i have to promise
to let you go at some point don't i
um
so mr depp
has decided you heard from ben you're
gonna see some really really terrible
text messages from johnny depp on how he
viewed amber heard he calls her some
horrific names but in the summer of 2016
he vows he vows he's going to haunt her
he vows she's going to suffer global
humiliation he says he's going to live
in her and she will never forget him and
he meant it
so
in in the summer of 2018 you heard ms
vasquez say he wants to clear his name
he can't be called a wife beater etc
but an article
an op-ed appeared on the sun times in
london
they called him a wife feeder it was
written by dan wooten the ceo or the
yeah the chief editor of the son at the
time and he is writing because johnny
depp is being cast in fantastic beasts
three
and so
he
he's the article is why is jk rowling
genuinely
so you will hear testimony
let me back up a little bit
so
you have heard from mr depp's team
that they are going to claim that amber
heard abused johnny depp you also are
hearing from them that he says that she
cut off his finger
when you look at the text messages and
you look at the emails you will see that
in every one of those mr depp
said to dr kipper to david heard amber's
father and to others i cut off my finger
you will see that he never throughout
the entire time he was married to amber
ever claimed that she hit him he never
ever throughout the time he was married
to amber heard claimed that she cut off
the finger
only two years later
does he for the very first time start
claiming she abused him and start
claiming that she cut off the finger i'm
going to ask you to look hard at the
evidence in this case because the
evidence is going to show that it never
ever came up before
now let's talk about the counter claim
for a few minutes there's a few
statements here
now they've said
why are you suing adam waldman you heard
from from ben
that adam waldman didn't come into
johnny depp's life until october 2016.
he wasn't there for any of their
marriage he doesn't have any personal
knowledge of their marriage everything
he does is based on johnny depp johnny
depp used adam waldman as his agent and
you will see a bunch of texts where he's
saying yeah man he's going after these
people he's doing all this stuff for me
he's suing my business manager he's
suing the lawyer he's going at you know
he's doing all this he's also going to
the press and making all kinds of
statements about amber hurt
and those statements
are as follows and
heather if you can pull up the first
the first one is adam waldman depp's
lawyer said afterwards amber heard and
her friends in the media use fake sexual
violence allegations as both a sword and
a shield depending on their needs they
have selected some of her sexual
violence hoax facts as the sword
inflicting them on the public and mr
depp
now there isn't any sexual violence hope
there isn't any hoax at all but he's out
there affirmatively stating that she's
got this conspiracy with her friends and
she's making these things up
and it's very very damaging and harmful
to her the testimony will be that these
depth fans take and run with these
things and you're going to hear from an
expert who talks about computer wise
when you search the hoax and you see
that it just spreads out into the
internet and the social media and
generates a lot of negative publicity
for amber statement two please
this was made in april of 2020.
depp's
lawyer adam weldman said various
discrepancies prove that nothing heard
and her friend said about the events of
may 21 2016 could be considered credible
quite simply this was an ambush a hoax
they set mr depp up by calling the cops
but the first attempt didn't do the
trick he told dailymailmail.com
the officers came to the penthouses
thoroughly searched and interviewed and
left after seeing no damage to face her
property so amber and her friend spilled
a little wine rough the place up and got
their story straight under the direction
of a lawyer and publicist and then
placed a second call to 9-1-1
now i've already told you all about the
events of of may 21 but i'm also you're
also going to hear from the second set
of officers
there's no way that amber was trying
with her friends to now get charges
pressed against johnny they cleaned
everything up they didn't want him in
there the absolute opposite of what he
says there the third statement if you
may
depp's attorney adam waldman said when
amanda day cabinet that's a friend of
ambers amber heard's best friend and me
too activist recancer support from his
herd and testifies against her you know
we have reached the beginning of the end
of ms hurd's abuse hoax against johnny
depp amanda day cadney never testified
against her but that's not the part that
we're claiming is the defamation it's
abuse hoax against johnny depp in other
words in all of these articles in all of
these articles he's saying that she
created an abuse hoax and you're going
to make those determinations of whether
that's true or not but what we're going
to show you is that that not only was
tremendously damaging to amber
emotionally and you're going to hear
from an expert on domestic violence and
intimate partner violence ipv about how
those triggers happen when you have
somebody who's gone through all of this
and she's trying to heal and she's
trying to get past this and then bam you
you come in there and you inflict this
and put this out in the public and
everybody runs there's over a million
you know we're going to tell you about a
million different searches on the
twitter from the from these different
hits how that impacts her emotionally
every time somebody calls her a liar for
what she went through and how hard she
tried to protect johnny depp so that his
children and the public never found out
about that johnny depp and how much that
has harmed her and and and how much
emotionally that's impacted her and
re-triggered and be triggered but we're
also going to talk to you about the the
reputational damages for that amber made
it through the divorce then she got cast
in aquaman a few of you have saw that
that was a blockbuster it was the
highest grossing movie in dc films
history ever up to this point over it
hit over a billion dollars in a very
short period of time it was a mega mega
hit she was moving forward
then she gets hit with these defamatory
statements and all of the depth
followings and the and the computer and
twitter and everything else nobody wants
to touch her well and you're going to
hear from an expert who's going to say
look at jason momoa look at gal gadot
look at other people who started coming
up in those tracks from just she was
justice league and then
aquaman look what they're getting
they're getting commercials they're
getting all kinds of different film
opportunities these are the things that
she would have gotten nobody will touch
her she's a pariah
and we're going to ask you as ben said
to hold mr depp responsible enough is
enough but we're also going to ask you
to hold him responsible
and and try to fully and fairly
compensate amber for what he has done to
her thank you very much
thank you mr huh
um based on time ladies and gentlemen i
think i'm going to release you for lunch
a little early so we can um just start
with the first witness when we get back
from lunch i think it's just a natural
break
so if you want to
go ahead and go with the deputy
just remember don't don't talk to
anybody about the case and don't do any
outside research okay we'll be back here
let's com let's get back at i'll give
you a little extra time to 145 okay just
give you some extra time downstairs okay
all right thank you if you go with
deputy looser
all right
okay
does somebody have the motion lemonades
for me i don't think i've received those
signed
orders
after lunch
okay first thing after lunch i get them
yes sir okay all right that's perfect
anything else
all right we'll be back at 145 then
thank you
go away
all right we ready for the jury or do we
have the motion lemonade
okay if i could just get those i'd
appreciate it
so we do have the order for miss
herzmotion's lemonade right mr depp's mr
moniz and i just agreed to it okay i
don't have it printed but i can tell you
your honor based on the representation
you gave me it is agreed okay and we
will have it printed as soon as i can
but we're not going to obviously hold up
court that's fine thank you very much
thank you your honor thank you mr murphy
all right are we ready for the jury then
okay
wow
so
yes
thank you ladies and gentlemen all right
your first witness
kristen zambrosky
all right kristen zambrosky
[Music]
is
she outside
okay
chris
do you only swear or affirm to testify
truthfully in this case under penalty of
law
you have to verbally answer ma'am
okay thank you
yes sir
good afternoon miss dombrowski
would you please state your full name
for the record
alisa christine dambrosky
miss dombroski
what relationship if any do you have
with johnny depp
he's my younger brother
how much older are you than johnny two
and a half years
mr brosky i'd like to ask you a few
questions about your and johnny's
childhood
where did you all grow up
um we were
born in kentucky and we
moved to florida when we were kids
who lived in your household with you and
johnny
our mom our dad
we have an older brother and older
sister and johnny and i
who was the youngest child in your
family johnny
would you please tell the jurors what
your relationship with johnny was like
when you were growing up
um
johnny and i were very close uh
with with having the older brother and
older sister we were the two younger
ones so we were really close and we
basically were together all the time
we played together we
played hot wheels
we you know played uh
batman and robin where
we each had a role in that
um
and he's probably going to be
embarrassed i say any of this but
um
you know we
practiced you know karate kicks with
each other and chopping we were just
friends we were like best friends
what was johnny like as a young boy
if you want to approach
as i was saying miss dombrowski uh what
was johnny like as a little boy
um he was he was a
a
shy sweet little boy he had a
very caring personality um
but also was a
he was a little bit of a a clown he
loved to
you know play tricks on us or try to
scare us he was a
very typical happy little boy objection
your honor i'm going exactly where i
said i was going all right i'll stay in
the the the last part of her answer
and we'll go forward thank you very much
your honor
ms dombrowski how would you describe
your parents relationship
that was complicated
would you please explain to the jury
what you mean when you say your parents
relationship was
complicated our parents were
they had two um completely
different personalities
and
where
our father was a
also very kind patient loving gentle
uh man
and our mom
was the opposite she was very high
strung very nervous
uh anxiety
angry
so they they were completely opposite
people
what was your mother's first name betty
did your mother betty ever get angry
with your father
yes
how would your mother express her anger
toward
your father
mom would
she would scream
she would yell at him
she would hit him
call him names
that kind of thing
did your father
ever
hit your mother back
no dad dad never reacted
um when mama hit him or scream at him
if he didn't hit her back
how if at all did he react
basically
um
he would let her
scream and get it out or hit and and and
be done and
the the
the way that you dealt with my mom the
way that he dealt with my mom was
he always tried to keep the peace so he
never wanted to
you know he didn't want to engage in
anything so he was very
you know sort of
he would step back and whatever it was
that she was angry about
he would try to go ahead and make sure
that he took care of whatever she
was insisting that he did is it fair to
say he did what she wanted yes it's very
fair to say he did
what if anything did you and johnny do
while your mother was hitting or
attacking your father
we would we would leave the area we
would run and hide we would go to our
room you know either we go to our room
together or
you know depending on where we lived you
know if our room was close
we would sort of run off and get away
from it
how did your mother treat
you and your brothers and sisters
well there's just there's a similarity
i'm sorry um in how she treated
dad
again she was a
very anxious high strung
she screamed she yelled
she
hit
she threw things
she called us names you know we each had
our own little special
set of names some
we wouldn't repeat but
um
so she gave each one of us a name my my
name for example was uh
violet
which to some people
it wouldn't seem like it's anything but
violet was my father's mother
and my mom hated
my father's mother
so that was my special name
one of them
did your mother have any special names
for johnny
yes she did
she had a few
again some did not repeat
her favorite i think was she called him
one eye
and she called in that because
when he was young
the the doctors thought he had a lazy
eye so they they would put a patch on
his good eye so that they would
strengthen the other eye so
she used that as you know a way to find
a
a new fun name for him
how did johnny respond when your mother
would call him one eye
he didn't respond in any negative way
that those names were
they were just a way of life
we we got used to them we
accepted all of it
putting aside the names did your mother
ever get angry with you
yes
did your mother ever get physical with
you
yes
she did but i was um also
very quiet very shy
and
i learned early on to stay back
so i was
i was more in the background because i
would constantly
sort of stay in the background to stay
away from trouble
miss dabrowski when she your mother did
get physical with you what forms did
that take
well she would she would hit us
she would throw things
she would have us go pick a switch you
know off of a tree you know so that that
would be what she could hit us with and
make sure that we got one that was
nice and green
so what i'm sorry i don't mean to wrap
why did it have to be nice and green
um if it wasn't a nice green
switch
twig it would it would snap
those didn't break if you got a dry one
they snap they don't
they don't work the same
did your mother ever get angry at johnny
yes
did you ever
observe your mother hitting johnny yes
how if at all did johnny react when his
mother would hit him
he was a typical little boy where if it
hurt he would cry
that was it i mean
for the most part you just wanted to get
away from it
did johnny ever hit
his mother back
no
what about when he got to be an older
boy did he ever resist or hit her back
no
no when he when he was older
even if she hit or threw things
he never went to that place he always he
would get away he would
you know leave the area go to his room
ms dombrowski did there come a time when
you left the family household yes
when did you leave the household
um i left when i was 17
i was pregnant and got married
and moved out into my own place
how did it feel when you left the family
to go out
and go to your own place
i think
there's a bitter sweetness to it um
i
i was really young i had just turned 17.
um but
i was so looking forward to this new
life that i could create that was
different
from
what we had at home and so it was a part
of me that was really happy to to be
able to do this really excited
and there was another part that was sad
because
i left behind my little brother and my
dad
if you could explain that a bit how how
did
if at all did your experience with your
mother
affect your ideas about what you
intended to do with your own family no
really early on
as a young child
none of what was happening in our home
felt good
um
and so as i got older
you know
both johnny and i actually
um
we decided that once we left once we had
our own home that we were never going to
repeat ever
anything
similar in any way
to our childhood
we were going to we were going to do it
different
so johnny felt the same way absolutely
when you left
the home to start your own family who
among the original four children were
left at home with your mother johnny
did there come a time when your parents
separated
yes
would you please tell the jury what
happened
there was uh
our father
one morning um
decided to uh
pack up everything and
and and leave early in the morning
um
we didn't we didn't know it at the time
i don't think but i i didn't i didn't
live that was at work
and then
i got a call from my mom in the
afternoon right after she got off work
she called me and
and i could
it was hard to understand her
voice um she sounded faint
and uh
kind of kind of groggy but she kept
saying he's gone he's gone he's gone
and i was trying to get out of her was
it dad and she said yes
your daddy
and and i said mom are you okay what did
you what did you what's going on you
know um
did you take your pills because she took
what she called nerve pills
and she said she had
um
i asked how many she she couldn't
tell me how many she took but i knew she
was
getting fainter
on the phone and it was
more clear to me that she was not in a
good way
so i called
i called our friend
our parents friend actually who was a
police officer and told him that he
needed to get to mom and
what was going on and so he got an
ambulance
to get over there to her
and this was after your father left yes
this is the day
mr broski do you know why your father
left
i know at the time um
because i did try to speak to him after
because mom
continued to not do well
at the time he said that
he said that they had had
the
last argument that he felt that they
could ever have he felt he needed
to leave home this time and
to be honest i i didn't really
understand
um
it had been so many years that he had
been taking all of the you know um
all of her
personality um
and i didn't really understand exactly
uh
fully what that last argument was uh why
it was so intense
um we did learn many years later in our
adult life
that
what he was referring to when he said
i guess the objections here say
uh your honor again i think it's it's
not offered for the proof it's offered
for
for the the
the abuse and the culture in which
i'll sustain the objection thank you
ronnie yes
did your mother
recover after she took the pills
yes
she continued to not be well but she she
recovered and after that
time
did she ever
take more than
more pills than she should have
she did but she didn't do it to the
degree that she had
at that point
and going back to the incident that you
described
do you know where johnny was at the time
your mother took those pills
johnny was home
did there come a time excuse me i'm
sorry i think he was i think he was
sleeping at the time
i think he woke up when
mom came out and the ambulance came so
he he saw all of that yes
did he see that she said
she testified he was in the home he was
in the home but was she in the home i
guess how did she know so i'll sustain
to foundation thank you
did there come a time when johnny left
his mother's house yes
and after johnny what did johnny do when
he left the house
jackson's foundation
all right i'll sustain his foundation if
you want to lay a foundation um
are you in were you in in communication
with your brother at the time
yes he he came and lived with me for
part of the time
so i think that
so what what was your what did your
brother do after he left your mother's
house
he
he
you know lived in different places he
lived with me and he lived with another
family
did you and johnny continue to
communicate with your mother betty after
you both left the home yes
yes we did
and after
what you have described why did you and
johnny
continue to communicate with your mother
objection foundation is to johnny
i think she's already laid the
foundation they're very close she was in
communication i'll sustain the objection
if you want for this particular question
why did you continue to communicate with
your mother
because she was our mom and we loved her
i mean
we we knew you know even when we were
younger that things weren't
they didn't feel right you know but but
what we understood was that
you know
mom had her own upbringing
you know so she had her own past and the
way she was raised would affect the way
she lived
um
and so
she in our mind she was doing the best
she could do
you know um we sort of
treated it like he
she
she did the best that she could do with
the tools that she was given
you know
um from her her life in the past
and
what we decided to do was we just
decided to get new tools we chose
different tools from that
and when you say we to whom are you
referring
i'm referring to johnny foundation
i'll overrule that objection next
question
thank you ron
did you ever live with your mother again
after you and johnny had left the house
i did i did live with her briefly
she had
gotten
diagnosed with asthma when we lived in
florida and
she needed to move to a drier climate so
johnny moved her to california to palm
springs for the drier weather
and i moved also so that she wouldn't be
alone
so i lived with her for a period then
and if you could just please elaborate
on what role if any johnny played in
your mother's move to palm springs
he he was
he was the only reason the move could
happen he
purchased her at home
and and paid to have everything moved
out there
did there come a time when your mother
ever left palm springs
she she moved from palm springs um
to be a bit closer to where johnny and i
lived in the la area
she lived there for a bit and then
ultimately she went back to kentucky
she had her siblings were still there
and a couple of them weren't doing well
so she wanted to be closer to them while
she could
and after she moved back to kentucky
from palm springs did there come a time
when your mother became chronically ill
yes
when was that 2011.
[Music]
would you please describe briefly
what her health condition was as of
2011.
well in 2011
[Music]
she was living in kentucky and we
received a call that she had been
diagnosed with
the final stages of parkinson's
but then when another doctor looked at
her scans
they
they felt it was something different so
we we have the scans brought
to a doctor in california
um
and they suggested that she come out and
see a neurologist right away
so
johnny got a plane um
a private plane and he and i we flew to
go pick her up and bring her back to
california to start seeing the doctors
and when she moved back to in 2011
to california was that
a permanent move
it became basically a permanent move um
she still she still had her house in
kentucky
in the hopes of you know her being able
to go back and forth
um
but her health
basically kept her in california so she
lived here or there
and by that time 2011 when she's moved
out to los angeles
had her treatment of you and johnny
changed in any way
yes mom's mom softened as she aged
she
she totally softened
and once your mother moved to los
angeles permanently in 2011
what role if any did your brother johnny
play
in her caretaking
protection foundation
all right i'll sustain as a foundation
did
to what extent if any
did your brother play any role in her
caretaking i think that's still
foundation objection
do you have knowledge of
whether your
brother
had any role in her caretaking
yes um
would you please explain to the jury
because i think her honor needs to hear
whether there's a foundation okay
i'm sorry um yes um
when we brought mom out you know over
over time she had multiple um
other uh illnesses that that came up and
uh johnny was
he he
dealt directly with the doctors like we
did
um
hired private nurses so that we could
make sure that you know mom was taken
care of you know
he
basically
johnny was the finance he took all
financial responsibility for anything
and everything mom could need or want
during this time all medical care
doctors hospitals nurses how do you know
that
i was directly involved
is it fair to say you saw
johnny do those things and have those
interactions i was there i was directly
involved in all of that
did you witness your brother having any
interactions with the doctors relating
to your mother's care yes
how often if at all
did your brother
visit
your mother betty after she came to live
in los angeles in 2011 objection
were you ever present uh with your
brother
and your mother when you all were
visiting
yes um
mom lived in a house
that was basically a across the street
from johnny
um
it was a house that he has on his street
and uh
i i was there you know quite a bit
johnny was
pretty much down there every day a
couple times a day
um
you know
mom
like she would see them all the time you
know one of her favorite things was
watching johnny take the kids to school
and waving at them because she never got
to do that before so
who were your brother's kids
oh um lily rose and jack
we'll get to that a little uh in a
little bit
um did there come a time
when the family was considering putting
your mother in a hospice
there was um
there were there were conversations with
the doctors that we should start to
consider that since we we weren't 100
sure
with the
variety of conditions that she had um
what we needed to do um
the idea of hospice
um was something that felt like since we
we didn't know a time frame
um
the idea of introducing
you know new nurses or something you
know at a certain point in someone's
life where they recognize there's a
difference um and that
could be that could be a you know
frightening for them so
we didn't want to instill any fear you
know johnny's
big on mom not having fear
um so instead that's when we hired
nurses so that the nurses could be there
24 7
and you know and and she would have
people continuously throughout her life
that she knew that they were friendly
and you know
cared for
did you actually have a conversation
with your brother about the possibility
of your mother going into hospice
yes
did
did he express an opinion about it yes
well this is where it all comes from
because
the idea again the idea of
hospice which is an amazing
thing
but for someone who when you don't know
with the variety of illnesses you don't
know what a timing is
um the idea of introducing it uh new
people is is something that becomes
almost a signal
you know and
this was a
very big discussion this is why the
nurses were hired
was this just one discussion or was it
as a series of discussions
it's i'm not uh asking for hearsay i'm
just asking about the whether it was
discussed once or a number out of rule
objection go ahead was this just one
discussion or were there more
discussions among you and your brother
about how to care how to best care for
your mother we we had we had continuous
discussions
as a matter of fact i mean i i there
were daily updates he knew every day
everything that was happening with mom
whether he was in town
out of town because he had he was
working or traveling
he had
i made sure because it's hard when you
know that someone wants to be
there um and they can't so i i made sure
to
to
fill him in on everything
it's not offered for the truth of it
all over rule's objection go ahead
did you ever see
johnny's children jack and lily rose
over at your mother's house across the
street from mr depp yes
mr brusque i'd like to change subjects
uh right now if that's all right and ask
you
to please tell us a little bit about
your work life
did there come a time when you worked in
the entertainment industry
yes
i started i started uh
working when we moved from florida to
palm springs this is why i lived uh for
a short period with my mom
[Music]
i ended up i got a job
at one of the studios in los angeles
which studio was that
it was columbia pictures i i was uh
my title was i was an executive
assistant
to the executive vice president of
comedy development
and what were your job responsibilities
when you started there
i
i handled
my executive's
daily schedule meetings budgets scripts
phone calls
and then in addition to that we had
there were four other executives and
they had assistance so
my desk was also to oversee those
assistants and
when we had writers come in i oversaw
those assistants as well it sounds like
a big job
it was a good job
how long did you work at columbia
pictures television in that role i think
it was about a year and a half
why did you leave after a year and a
half
um
[Music]
columbia itself started folding
different departments and ours our
comedy development being one of them
um
and so some of the employees that worked
there went to work for sony or tristar
other sort of arms of the
of the corporation
and i was the last one there um sort of
wrapping up the department to go on to
my next
job
so after you wrapped up the trend
transition the closing up of the
department what did you do in terms of
your work life
i went to work with my brother
and what capacity when you say your
brother would uh to whom you referring
i'm sorry i'm sorry when you say your
brother uh to whom are you specifically
referring i went to work with my brother
johnny
uh what type of things
did you do for your brother johnny
um
similar things to what i was doing with
[Music]
the other
boss that i worked for before but
um with johnny he was
i was helping him anyway uh as a sister
um bits and pieces before i started
working with him so there were things
like travel and
you know meetings setting meetings
making sure he had his you know the
scripts that were coming in and he knew
you know all the information about them
um
and you know any kind of publicity stuff
that he had to do
uh
because
i really
started to do this job with him because
there was one time
that i had gone to his house and i was
helping him get ready to
go on a trip and his uh ticket i read it
out loud and it said standby and i said
why are you on standby he had no one
looking out for that kind of stuff
you know so
i did all of that
how if at all did your
work for your brother treat
change over time
well over time it sort of grew
well not sort of it did grow
his agent
i worked
sort of hand-in-hand with his agent and
you know as she got to know me more and
i got to know her more
there were
other parts of her job actually that she
would give to me so you know instead of
just doing
scheduling meetings and calendars and
travel
now i become a person who's talking to
producers or
you know
as it expands you know
all the executives at the studios and
studio heads and
you know become a part of contract
negotiation et cetera it just
grew
what role if any did you play
in dealing with johnny's movie contracts
contracts i am
because i know the history and because
uh
there's a certain amount of
uh
parts of life that
are important you know to a human being
not just to an actor but to a human
being and i know the human being
i was part of
mostly
negotiating parts like there's an area
called perks and
perks means
um anything and everything that an actor
would need in order to perform his
duties
and in order to you know to also move
right to the to the location to do the
duty so
i i was part of all important dates that
you know needed to be considered in a
calendar um
making sure the house was
what he needed to have for the family
the travel to get there making sure he
had his staff
drivers security
pretty much
anything necessary was was in that mrs
dombrowski can you give the jury some
examples of some of the things
you put on the perks list
uh sure um
we
[Music]
it was a
it was
really important um
you know as johnny had a family it was
really important to be able to
make sure that we
were given the opportunity to find the
right accommodations and
accommodations for
the children of you know house that you
know could you know
give them a home away from home with a
garden
um all the travel to make sure that they
all get there
there were really important dates
that uh
we carved out
in every contract um for johnny's kids
for their birthday he never wanted to
miss their birthday so if he wasn't able
to be with him because of filming it was
built into the contract that he had
their birthday off and he would have the
day before and the day after so that
he'd be able to travel to get to them
and then get back to working
so
in addition to that i mean
there's there's there's quite a bit
we also had it built in that
if if he was to be away from his kids
filming if the kids couldn't travel and
family couldn't travel to be there um
we had in his contract that he would be
able to fly back to them
from wherever he is every two weeks so
he didn't go beyond every two weeks
not seeing his children
you know it's that kind of stuff that
you know
was important
ms dombrowski do you know what a
personal manager is in the context of
the entertainment world i do
what is it if you could explain it to
the jury because i just learned it
myself
well i
i believe it's basically what i
a lot of what i was doing um
they um
they work with the their client on
uh
maintaining different items in their
personal life as well as uh
you know projects coming in production
all of the representatives um
it's a it's a sort of a big scope of
duties
has anyone ever referred to you as
johnny's personal manager i have been
called that before yes
do you perform uh the responsibilities
of your of
being johnny's personal manager
i i did
i did do you still work with
johnny
yes
do you
also work with any of johnny's companies
or strike that uh
does does your brother have any
companies associated with him
he has a production company called
infinitum nile
what type of
company is infinitive nile it's a
production company
we develop you know projects uh for
films or television or
you know different things and put it
putting aside your responsibilities as
your brother's personal managers
what role if any do you play in
infinitum nile
uh i'm president of infinitum now
when did you start working at an
infinitive nile
um from the
beginning
in 2004 i think we started in july 2004
and would you please explain to the jury
uh some of the some of your
responsibilities as president of
infinitive nile
my duties as president were to
i oversaw
um
everything within the company um
the the staff where we were developing
projects uh
where you know
maybe there's a book that people want to
develop into a film or a tv show or
different ideas so i oversaw that
oversaw all the all of the development
um
their schedules with meetings with
different people to to take those
projects out
to to pitch uh
i i i there's so many
tasks in that job i don't know how to
i don't know how to really lay them out
miss dombrowski when did the first
pirates of the caribbean movie come out
i think it was 2003
i think
what what was your brother's role in
pirates um he he was captain jack
fair
sparrow
say that was the lead that was
that was the lead
how did the first pirates of the
caribbean
movie fair at the box office
it it it did very well i think it
surprised people
and did very well um
people really
they loved you know the
they love the entertainment of it you
know the total ride
did the success of pirates one change
johnny's career in any way
i i would have to say yes um
the success of pirates one
it became um
johnny
with that role and and other studios and
everybody seeing the success of
that film and and and how the audiences
reacted to that character
um
they were there was a whole lot more
people wanting to be in business with
him
and did the success of pirates one
change his personal life in any way
for his day-to-day life it it did it did
um
because where
prior to that you know he was
able to go out um
somewhat you know he could
you know go to different stores go to
bookstores go to restaurants um when
pirates
one came out
after that
he was much more recognizable now you
know so many people loved that character
and so he was much more recognizable so
it became harder for him to to go out in
public
without having a lot of people come
around that you know
rightfully so wanted to meet him and
um
but then it it also became a
really big and so we had even people
that were chasing you know chasing in
cars so we had at that point we had to
we had to
have get security team to kind of come
in and help us manage how this all works
you know who is jerry judge
jerry judge was
he was basically johnny's head security
when did jerry judge start coming to
work with with your brother
well we um
we started working with jerry judge
back in the 90s
um
because jerry had his own security
company
in london
and uh
when we would go over there for press or
premieres or whatever jerry was the one
you know that
set everything up and and we became
really close with him back then
and as things grew with pirates
we brought him over more and more you
know for some of the items that we had
some of the work that he had it was a
show or whatever um or
and brought him on and then he started
just working basically on every film
with us
after pirates probably right around that
time
how long did jerry judge work with you
and johnny
well again um
we met him in the 90s so and around
pirates is what 2003
um and jerry was with us up until we uh
we lost him
when did you lose him uh we lost him
a couple years ago to cancer
what was jerry's relationship like with
johnny
um
objection foundation
did you ever see
jerry judge interact with your brother
sustain the objection that's the leading
the next question that's fine
thank you
what if any uh observations
did
were there any times when you saw your
brother interact with jerry judge
i i saw i saw the two of them interact
quite a lot um and uh
they they they loved each other they
were like you know
jerry thought of him as his like a son
and sometimes as a brother
um
they really did love each other and so
much respect both ways
all of that
i don't think there's any basis to
strike that i think it was most
responsive all over the objection go
ahead thank you runner
and i wanted to touch on something you
mentioned a few moments ago when you
were referring to
mr depp's children
i believe you said it was uh daughter
lily rose and
jack
who was the mother of johnny's children
vanessa parody
did
johnny and vanessa parody
ever live together as a couple
yes
how long did johnny and vanessa parody
live together as a couple
i i think they were together
14 years
and did their children live with them
during the 14 years yes
how much time would you say you spent
with
johnny vanessa lily rose and jack
when when they were in
los angeles i
i would say i saw them all daily
um our office
where we work our office is only it was
only 10 minutes from their house so
i would make trips back and forth or
every day after work i would go straight
to the house so i i saw them daily
would you please explain to the jury
what it was like spending time with
johnny and his family
he was great um
it was great it was a normal happy
family you know you go there and the
kids are playing and you know
making dinner everybody having dinner
cleaning up together sitting around
laughing it was it was great
did you have occasion to see your
brother interact with his children
yes
yes i did
what did you observe what can you tell
the jury about what you observed
um
he's
i'm proud to say he's uh
he's one of the most
devoted
fathers i think that i've ever seen like
everything
everything in life was about the
children but when he was with the kids
like the attention that he would give
them
you know
it was just
constant playing with them listening to
them you know laughing with them reading
to them barbies i mean you you name it
and he
he was there
did you ever observe
johnny treating his children
the way you saw his mother treat him
when he was young
no
have you ever seen johnny
hit either of his children
no
have you ever heard
your brother raise his voice at his
children
no
you may have touched on it earlier and
if so i apologized
but how if at all did johnny communicate
with his children when he was shooting a
film
objection foundation
were you trying to sustain the objection
if you want to lay the foundation um
did you have occasion to obser were you
ever with your brother when he was
shooting a film
yes
did you have occasion to observe your
brother communicating with his children
while you both were there on set
yes
yes
so
no please go ahead
when
excuse me when when johnny was filming
most of the time
the family was with him the family would
travel and go
you know just like i said earlier
we would get a house and garden and
and all of that to make sure that there
was a home
so his family was with him most of the
time
what about when the children got older
and they started going to school did
that change in any way
it changed in that um
they you know they didn't want to
disrupt the children's lives when they
were going to school so if if dad had to
go off and go work and the children
stayed home
um this is where we get into we still
we still maintained a home for the
family
wherever he was filming you know um
because they would if they had the
opportunity to come back and forth
um
and but at the same time johnny would he
would travel back every two weeks
you know to see his kids and when you
say he would travel back who was it who
made those travel arrangements i made
the travel arrangements
did you have occasion to observe johnny
interact with the mother of his children
vanessa paradis over the 14 years they
were together yes i did would you please
tell the jury what you observed about
the interactions between mr depp and
vanessa
this is not this is directly uh i'll
allow observations all over the place
thank you very much
what did you observe about mr depp's
interactions with the mother of his
children
they
they were a a great couple i mean first
you could see that they were friends
um
they they just
they were happy together they they you
know um they got along great it was it
was a happy normal
i'll sustain the objection at this point
then
all right
did you ever hear
your brother yell at vanessa
it's not leading
to what extent if any have
that wasn't the question mr chair of
course
okay i'll sustain on that objection next
question
what if any violence did you
observe
[Music]
i'll between go ahead and finish your
question first well if i think you're
going to sustain the objection perhaps i
should read we should move on yes okay
okay
did vanessa ever claim
that johnny ever physically abused her
no foundation calls for your say all
right
your say objection
it's not it's not offered for the proof
of the
it's what she observed what she heard
she was the personal manager of honor
that's what we hear say i'll sustain the
objection thank you
did there come a time when johnny and
vanessa separated after 15 14 years
yes
how would you describe their
relationship today
same objection
all right excuse me as well and
foundation i don't think it calls for
hearsay your honor she's the she's just
i understand but it's the character
evidence issue so i'll sustain the
objection
who is amber hurt
my brother's ex-wife
when did you first meet amber hurt
i first met her when she
came to the office
for casting on rum diary um
probably late
2008
i think
some somewhere in there
did you see miss hurt on set
yes what if anything did you observe
when she was working on set
i mostly observed you know some of the
you know i was there for some of the
scenes
um and in in between
you know
she was a bit sort of like you know
standoffish had all you know people you
know coming around her but i don't
really
i don't really have that much time with
her on set
when was um rum diary actually released
2011.
was johnny in that movie yes
what role if any did you have with
respect to run diary i was one of the
producers
and after seeing miss heard on the set
in 2009-2010
when was the next time you saw a
misheard
i think the
the next time i saw her was
we were um
we were we were promoting rum diary
towards the end of 2011 i think
um i was not able to go on the full
promotional tour
where we do
screenings for people around the country
[Music]
but i was able because my mom was sick
but i was able to attend
the one in los angeles so i saw her
at that
event
what uh did you observe so you attended
the premiere
i attended the premiere and uh
and um the
dinner afterward yes
would you please describe for us what
you observed at the premiere
at the dinner at the dinner
because i i i sat outside at the
premiere i didn't actually watch the
movie i'd already seen it
i sat at the same table
with
some of the other
people involved in the cast
so i saw
johnny and amber you know they were
seated together i saw them talking quite
a bit and
she seemed very friendly that night yes
did there come a time when you learned
that johnny and amber were romantically
involved
yes
when was that
i i don't recall exactly
i know it was some time
after the wrong diary
premiere
to what extent did you have occasion to
observe
johnny and miss her together early in
their relationship
i would see them
there were times when she would come and
you know
visit
our mom you know
um i would see her then i would see the
two of them then
i didn't really spend a tremendous
amount of time
with her had you formed any impression
of misheard at that time based on your
observations
i i did
i did
look um
i didn't i didn't know her very well um
and i would spend time
like i said she would you know she would
come to my mom's house i
sat with her and my mom
um
what was your impression of
amber based on her observation she's
describing what she observed
i don't i don't think that's right
you're on earth she's describing what
she observed
but
we won't approach for a moment
um
did there come a time
when
your
did there come a time when your brother
and miss heard
started to live together
yes
and
when did that occur approximately if you
recall i don't i don't recall the timing
um
i don't recall the time frame i
believe
they had moved downtown
um to the eastern columbia building
but i don't remember exactly when that
was
uh what type of structure was the
eastern columbia building was that a
freestanding house or was it apartments
it's apartments and he had
he had the penthouses on the top floor
how many
penthouses did your brother own on the
top floor of the eastern columbia
building
i think it was i think it was five
apartments
do you know who lived in those five
apartments when your brother and miss
heard went to live there
i know um
i know who lived down there um i i know
isaac a a friend of johnny's name isaac
lived down there
um
i know
amber's friend rocky and her boyfriend
uh lived in one of the penthouses um
amber's sister whitney
lived in one of the penthouses
when you say rocky are you referring to
rocky pennington yes
and was her boyfriend josh drew joshua
did
rocky pennington and josh drew
pay any rent to your
brother no
what about
um
miss heard's sister whitney did she pay
any rent to your brother no
do you do you know why
uh your brother allowed them to live
rent free in his
in his uh at the ecb because they were
they were
hold on i'm sorry man i'm sorry uh
foundation
we asked do you know why so if she knows
she can answer allow it all over
she was his personal manager that's fine
did you arrange for
handling a lot of your brother's uh
bills
i would give them to the business
manager um
but i
i believe
they were amber's family and friends
that's why he let them live there
how often did you see your brother when
he was living with miss heard at the ecb
penthouses
we didn't
we didn't see him as often i didn't see
him as often
[Music]
he pretty much
stayed down there he didn't come back
you know towards where we were in west
hollywood
very often unless he had a reason to
and on those occasions when you did see
your brother what observations
did you
make
he uh
he was always in a hurry when he was
able to come back he you know he could
never sit and spend
the time you know he
it felt like he was always trying to you
know get back uh downtown
he he
he just seemed so much sadder he did not
seem himself he was
he was always
his
his person was much
just sadder
did in that time period
when your brother and miss heard were
living at the ecb
did you have occasion to observe them
together
on occasion
would you please describe for the jury
what you observed on those occasions
when you saw your brother and miss her
together
i mean there's
different occasions of
i've seen them together
when they've come into the office i mean
when you saw them together did they
appear
to get along
all right i'll sustain this to leading
all right next question
did you ever
witness them arguing
objection leading
all right i'll sustain this stain is
deleting
did
in your capacity as johnny's
personal manager
do you know whether
your brother and amber ever tried uh
ever travel together
yes
they did travel together
there were
i mean there were times when you know
when johnny had to go do press or
film
they travel together
what type of travel arrangements did you
make for the two of them when they
traveled together
we
we would get
a private plane
that took them to
whatever the destination was
[Music]
and make sure that we had you know the
hotel accommodations
taken care of
um
part part of
part of what we did uh was to always
make sure that we anticipated you know
everything so we would do the uh
the travel the hotels uh cars drivers
i would i would make sure that there was
an extra hotel room
you know for
trips when they would go
would you why did you make sure there
was an extra hotel room when
johnny and miss heard
went on trips together
because their
objection to the extent that the answer
calls for hearsay
all right i don't believe it okay that's
fine
you can answer ma'am oh thank you
um
[Music]
i booked the extra hotel rooms um
because
if johnny was at home
um or
you know anywhere like that he was able
to
if they argued he was able to leave the
room leave the argument and go
like he's always done and hide
in a different room to get away from it
when when they were traveling for
you know the different reasons for press
or whatever
and we booked the hotel rooms
i wanted to make sure that there was an
extra room
you know
because
it wasn't unusual didn't mean for them
to have an argument so i wanted to make
sure that there was an extra room
did your brother ever have occasion to
use that extra room that you booked for
him
yes objection foundation all right a
sustainable foundation if you want to
lay a foundation i think the foundation
was she made all of the travel well i
can actually lay it through some other
questions as well she was a person
personal manager
um
whose idea was it to book
an extra room for your brother when he
traveled
it was my idea
and why did you do that
it was my idea because you know um i saw
a repeat happening in life when we were
when we were kids and and
arguments and fighting would start to
happen our first thing was to go and
hide and
you know uh get away from it and
since i recognized uh
what felt to be
a pattern that was a repeat pattern from
his childhood
i've
i wanted to make sure that there was a
place that he could do just that
mr two the question was do you did did
mr def ever use the extra room and the
objection was foundation so if you want
to lay a foundation of how she would
have known that he used that extra room
and if not based on hearsay that's
that's the issue
all right i'll i'll strike that okay go
ahead thank you honor
did you ever book an extra did you book
your brother's hotel accommodations
during the 14 years
that he when he was with vanessa parody
yes
did you ever book an extra room when he
was with her objection
no
overall allow that one go ahead
if you could repeat it i don't think the
jury heard that i'm sorry
no i did not
did you
ever hear
your brother
and miss heard argue
objection calls for hearsay
so you may answer that no
did you ever
see or hear any physical altercation
between your brother
and miss hurt no
[Music]
what can you tell us about what you did
observe
of your brother and misheard together
what to to me
um
to when i saw them to me um
he was always trying to make sure he was
always trying to make her happy
he always made effort to to sort of make
her happy i
i think she had a very uh
she's a very strong personality
um
and and my brother's personality came
off much more soft at that point
to me
did you observe
any occasions in which miss heard was
nice to your brother
yes i've seen her be nice to him
would you please explain that
i
i i've seen her be nice and and you know
uh
you know offering to you know
bring him a drink or you know
get them
whatever i mean just a typical like a
typical nice i've seen that
have you witnessed any occasions on
which ms heard wasn't nice to your
brother i i have actually would you
please describe those to the jury yeah
um
we had
i had a
on one occasion because this one this
one really
this one really staked with me um on
on
one occasion
um
we were i was at the office and i had a
meeting
um
with dior
who had wanted to uh
sit with johnny and um
talk about you know working together
and
amber had come in and asked if she was
interrupting us and uh
we said no and we weren't supposed to
really talk about the meeting with
anyone um but johnny johnny told amber
that uh
i had just had a meeting with dior and
that you know they were interested
in
him
um
her
her reaction
to that was
she was in disbelief and sort of
disgust
because she said
dior why why would your want to do
business with you they're about class
and they're about style and you don't
have style
you know so it was a
the insulting kind of taking away that
one moment
you know that insult is
there
you know i've i've seen i've seen the
insults
multiple times actually
what
if anything did you hear
ms heard say about mr duff's physical
appearance
she called him an old fat man
how did he respond
he had he
i believe he's heard her call him that
himself
now mr nebraska i'd like to ask you
about a specific event
that is relevant to this case
um and just for to for the background
i'll say did there come a time in 2013
when your brother was working with keith
richards of the rolling stones on a
documentary
yes
were you present
yes i was i was present out there was
misheard there as well
yes
if you could please tell the jury how
physically close you were or how far you
were
from ms hurd while the three of you were
on the set
i was i was um
i was right next to her
um they had they had gotten there and
i was close enough that i hugged her
and and was standing next to her
it was a small
set
and when you were standing next to her
and when you were hugging her
what if any marks or physical injuries
did you see
i i didn't see anything
did you
observe your brother's interactions with
miss heard
while the three of you were on the set
yes
what if anything did you observe her
doing
they
they were fine
she was
laughing and happy and holding his hand
and
you know leaning on him
hugging him
did your brother hug him back hug her
back
yes but it was mostly her hugging
and switching switching subjects from
that
time on the set
did there come a time when you learned
that johnny was going to marry miss hurd
yes
and this is a little complicated so i'm
just going to ask you in a narrative
form
i understand there was a a wedding and
that there was uh
there were a couple of ceremonies if you
could just please describe that to the
jury um
they
there was a wedding uh celebration that
was
put together
on the island
so
they had us
like a wedding ceremony
on the island
but prior to
going to the island to do that they
actually got married in los angeles
because they
they had to get married in los angeles
because they couldn't get married
you know paperwork etc
on the island so they got married in l.a
how did you learn
that they were going to get married
we were we were already working on um
the celebration part and i knew
i knew that the date was
at some point
they were going to pick a date to
to try to get married in los angeles
but i didn't i didn't know the actual
date that had been decided until he
called me
which was
pretty much right before the date
what was your reaction upon hearing from
your brother
that he was going to marry miss her
i was a
i was um
scared i was
devastated actually that it was uh it
was going to happen as as a as quickly
as it was being pushed for
um
i i actually
tried to talk him
into just
just waiting a little bit longer just a
little bit and not
not rushing
why did you want him to wait a little
bit longer
there had been
there have been conversations about
a prenuptial agreement that had been
going on
for a while
um
and as the date was approaching
you know for the
island ceremony
there was no success in the prenuptial
conversations and
i knew it was important um his
representatives
had explained the importance and i knew
it was important to him for his children
and
i we were rushing to do something
without
his children being protected
specifically if you could explain to the
jury what involvement you had in those
discussions about a prenuptial agreement
what was your involvement in the
discussions involving the pre-nuptial a
prenuptial agreement
mostly it was uh
i spoke with
the attorneys and the representatives so
that they they explained the importance
of it and they explained the reasons
behind it move to strike hearsay
i'll allow it
that means you can keep going okay so
i'm sorry
i'm sorry um
so that uh
so that we could have further
conversation and and uh
with johnny and and
they
there was an attorney that they
coordinated with for
um for amber
um
so that that was
where i was involved
in the coordinating that part
which side wanted a prenup
johnny's side wanted a prenup
and i believe what you said may have
gotten lost
why did johnny's side want a
prenup well the prenup was to to make
sure that his children were protected
that's jack and lily rose jack and lily
rose yes
did your brother and miss heard ever
sign a prenup
no
why not
i
amber didn't sign it
did you end up
despite your misgivings
did you end up
attending the wedding
uh between or the ceremony
between your brother and miss heard on
the island in the bahamas
yes i did but i i also attended the
actual wedding
um
in los angeles and that's that preceded
the celebration in the bahamas is that
correct
did you have occasion to speak with
ms heard either
at the ceremony the formal ceremony
in los angeles or the celebration in the
bahamas
i did um
at the actual
at the actual ceremony um in los angeles
they they uh they had the ceremony at
our mom's house
um
and at that ceremony
i didn't have occasion to really speak
with amber
she rocky and whitney i
don't believe
wanted necessarily to speak with me on
that day i did
i did after the ceremony was done
i was standing not far from them and
they were having a conversation
they were having a conversation actually
about excuse me about
should they leak the
information that they had already gotten
married at the house
to the press so that they could
maybe they didn't have to worry about
the island when they did the celebration
um
and amber
amber actually
reached out to me and said because i was
standing
seven eight feet away from her um asked
my opinion
you know what i thought about that which
i
i basically said i didn't know why they
would do it since
all the information for the island was
already out and then it wasn't going to
help them i didn't know why they would
want to leak it at all
but it was up to them
i saw her on the island as well um but
on the island she was
actually extremely friendly
uh when
when i got there
because if i'm honest um i i debated
going i
i
i didn't really want to um
i almost didn't but i i took my dad
dad wanted to go and uh
i wanted to make sure that i showed up
anyway because i wanted to make sure
that
honestly that my little brother would
know that i was
going to be i was always going to be
around no matter what
but amber was extremely friendly and
thanked me for coming to her special day
you know it was a very big day for her
can you remember any other interactions
you had with
ms hurd or your brother on the island of
the
celebration
interactions on the island
not really and when was the
next time you saw amber heard
after the celebration on the island
it was it would have been
would have been when she came back from
australia
and i i will get to that your honor um
is it possible
for us to take a very quick break sure
you're gonna are you gonna you still
have quite a bit of direct left eyes oh
uh i do have a fair amount okay all
right ladies and gentlemen won't we go
ahead and have you take your afternoon
break of 15 minutes okay again don't do
any outside research and not talk to
anybody about the case i know you're
going to hear me say it so much
thank you
thank you your honor
i haven't said yet
so
let's see
i want to make sure i haven't said yet
no it's okay i usually wait till the
jury goes out so we can make sure
all right
so why don't we just go ahead and make
it at 3 30 then so it's close enough
it'll take 15 minutes for three okay
sure
would you mind instructing the witness i
think this will go for all the ways is
that on the breaks they're not to
discuss their testimony all right you
understand that
ma'am since you are right now uh on the
stand you can't discuss this case not
even with the attorneys okay so don't
discuss it with anybody till we get you
back here in 15 minutes okay all right
thank you thank you
are we ready for the jury
okay you ready
just
before he takes the witness back you're
on really pleased we have that second
order fully endorsed very pleased yes
both of them are completed that's great
i'll have an entry for my diary won't
you
thank you
thank you so much
thank you ronnie all right yes sir
yes we're ready
let's go
system
so
all right if we can just
be seated and we're ready to start again
okay yes mr two thank you your honor
good afternoon again miss dambrosky i'm
told that both you and i need to speak a
little closer to our microphone i'm
sorry thank you
and when we took the break i think you
were just uh testified that the next
time you had seen
miss heard
was when she had just returned from
australia
yes
what what if anything did you discuss
with miss heard
when she returned from australia
uh we excuse me we met for
dinner late
a late dinner
and
she was
she was telling me that she and johnny
had had a
a fight
in australia
and i was
i was trying to talk to her about the
idea that
that kind of fighting is
not normal it's too much you know um
it's it's it's not okay um
but she uh she told me that i needed to
basically get down off my cross and
my mom business
she said that johnny
liked that she was feisty you know she
was feisty and then he loved it and
that jerry judge and i
needed to stay out of her marriage so
that was the basic
conversation
did you respond at all when miss heard
told you to get off your cross
i just kept
saying that
fighting is not
normal this kind of fighting is not
normal
how close were you to misheard when you
were having this conversation we were
right next to each other right
like right here
did you see any marks or any
discoloration on her face
now miss dambrosky i'd like to shift
gears again and
ask you about
the period
in april and may of 2016
if you could please let us know
as of april 2016
what was the state of your mother's
health
um
excuse me
mom had been um
[Music]
she had been in the hospital
for quite some time and uh
like a long steady pace from november so
by april she was
we knew that she was
towards the end of her life so
um
that's what april basically was and it
went into may
in may we gathered everybody to come say
goodbye to her
how often if at all did you visit your
mother in april 2016.
she was in the hospital so i was
i was with her
pretty much every day i was a 24 7 when
i wasn't uh
you know at the office or something you
know
did you ever see johnny at the hospital
yes
how often did johnny did you see johnny
at the hospital in april 2016.
i don't know how often i saw him i mean
he would come and see her you know
regularly um even before that when
there was a period we were trying to
help her communicate and he
you know brought in
you know
different type tools of
pens pencils you know of drawing crayons
just to try to help her
communicate he he came as often as he
could he was
he was there quite a bit
and when you said you called the family
together in may would you please
explain what you meant
we were told by
by the doctors that
mom was at a point where there was
nothing else
that we could uh do for her
and um
so that we should start calling anybody
that wanted to you know come and
you know spend
a little bit of time and say their
goodbyes so we did that
we did that in may
and and moving ahead to
may 19
2016
what was your mother's condition that
day
she was she was basically in a coma she
was medicated and
and just on
machines
uh
life support where it was you know
slowly
going away
on may 19. how do you know that i i was
with her
did you see uh your brother in the
hospital that day
yes
what happened the next day may 20th
2016.
well my mom passed away that morning um
we had all the family was there johnny
was there with his kids
um
until the wee morning hours of may you
know uh
may 20th um
my kids uh my sister
we were all there spending our last bits
of time and
everybody else had gone home
um
and mom passed away probably a few hours
after that maybe five six hours
after that
who was with your mother when she passed
i was
who if anyone
told johnny that your mother had
i'm
passed
take take your time
um i did i i um
i called him and i called my um our
other siblings to tell them
and i'm sorry i know this is
painful um
how did johnny react when you told him
that your mother had passed
well he was uh
he was sad but there was a also there's
a relief that you know suffering is has
done
so
he was mostly trying to make sure that i
was okay and i was going to
leave and not stay there and
you know sort of take on every
thing
about myself so we asked about how you
were doing oh
yes that became
quite a big topic
yes
ms dombrowski did you see
johnny the next day saturday may 21
2016.
i did um
i had i had
i'd gone to um
his house
the the night we lost mom
i think we all kind of gathered our
children right and i had i had my sister
with me
so i had driven her back on the saturday
and we were going to go to the funeral
home so
i was while i was waiting for her i went
to go check on johnny
and see if he was okay
and wanted to go
and did you check on johnny saturday
morning the 21st yes
yes i went
i went to see him
um because he was
we had talked about maybe he would also
go to to the funeral
home but
when i got there he seemed he seemed
upset because he and amber had
been fighting
what else happened when you first met
with your brother
on the morning of the 21st when you were
talking about going to the funeral home
i just i
i went to go see if he was going to go
with us i got there he was upset
excuse me because they were fighting
um
i
got upset
because of the day that was chosen to
fight
um
but i i went ahead and left and went to
the uh
to the funeral home with my sister
and then came back that evening
why were you upset
about their fighting on that day in
particular
our
we had just lost our mom
the day before
so
i feel like that you know there might be
the need for
a little compassion no fighting on that
day
did johnny end up going with you to the
funeral home that day
no i went ahead and went
um
and he was he was gathering his stuff
because he had to go pick up some
items because he was going to go on tour
did you see johnny again that day once
you left him to go to the funeral home
yeah i i came back
um
that evening i came back i
was taking care of my sister for a bit
and then
before i left to go home
i stopped at his house
to make sure that he was okay you know
[Music]
and
i saw him then
and what happened when you went over to
see that he was okay
he was uh
he was talking to a couple of people i
you know i
saw him briefly he he seemed to be all
right and
i spoke to jerry judge
and
they had they had just come back from
him picking up
items down at um
at the downtown at the loft
so when you
met him the second day that time
strike that when you met him the second
time that day on may 21
did you meet with him at his sweets or
house or at the ecb
no i went to the sweets house he had
gone down to
[Music]
the
the penthouse to pick up some of his
stuff
because he was
going to be leaving you know to go on on
tour um
and i just stopped by after after they
had just gotten back
and as of that time the evening of may
21 your mother had just passed
what plans if any
had been made for
a funeral service for your mother
we we hadn't made any plans for a
funeral service
we wanted to wait until we could get you
know all the friends and family because
we weren't expecting the
date necessarily um but we wanted to
wait till we can get all friends and
family to come together to have more of
a
like a dinner like a celebration like
mom would want at her favorite place so
we we waited we decided to schedule it
like a month or so out
instead of immediate
so you had referred to your brothers
having plans to go on tour
that next week obviously not knowing
that his mother was going to pass
what
if any other
formal events had been planned for that
next week before he was going on tour
well he was he had a um
[Music]
he had the premiere for
alice
that was on the monday night
mom passed on friday
um
and the premiere was monday night
um
and then he was going to take a flight
after that immediately after
the premiere he had to get on a plane to
go to
new york
to
meet the band and go on to europe
and when you say alice just so the jury
may understand if you could please
explain to them what alice is oh i'm
sorry um alice uh
and and
i'm so sorry right now
i don't know if it's alice through the
looking glass maybe was that one's name
or
the alice in wonderland disney series
where he played uh
hatter
and so that
that premiere for alice in wonderland
was going to be on monday
and what day was
mr depp
planning to go on tour with his music
band
he had to be there tuesday morning he um
so we
we had to schedule it it was very tight
we scheduled a
plane for him
immediately
after the premiere
he would get on the plane
so he was expected to leave on tuesday
so how long was he supposed to be on
tour
i believe it was a couple of months
something like that
going back to the premiere how if it all
did your mother's passing
affect the premiere of alice in
wonderland
we didn't
we didn't let anybody know that mom had
passed away we kept that really close um
to just our you know just family and
friends
because he because he had to go to the
premiere and
with the premiere he's on
the the carpet and on the carpet he does
a lot he does interviews and
it didn't feel right
on many levels
to
have
him
where people knew that mommy passed away
and um
while he's trying to do interviews to to
sort of you know give their condolences
and their sympathies and all of that so
we
we kind of kept it
just with us so that it wouldn't become
a
you know a worldwide thing and he could
just
do what he was supposed to do and do his
job
did you think he could handle hearing
all that sympathy at the premiere
i i didn't think he should handle i
didn't think i thought i thought it
would be very hard on him
you know
it would be very hard question after
question and condolences and
did there come a time when miss heard
filed for divorce from your brother
yes
when was that
i learned
i learned that she had filed
on the tuesday morning
[Music]
after that premiere of the tuesday
morning i was at the funeral home and i
got a call from
the attorney to let me know that she had
filed
where was johnny
when you learned that ms hurd had filed
for divorce
he was he was already
in new york and
getting ready to travel to europe
for the tour
how did you react initially
when you heard from
mr duff's attorney that ms hurd had
filed for divorce
i mean i think understandably you know i
i
the timing
[Music]
of
this
it made me
sick actually it really made me
feel ill it made me
sad frustrated i don't i don't i can't
even find the
word
to describe
um
how i felt when i heard
that the divorce was filed the day after
you know
while i'm at the funeral home
you didn't think the timing of ms hurt's
filing was appropriate
i
i did not i thought i thought it would i
thought something like that might have
been able to wait
did there come a time when you learned
that ms hurd had also filed for
a restraining order against johnny
yes
yes i think i heard that also from the
attorney
i believe
i believe the day before
um
she was i think i it was a thursday i
think i learned that one
so this was two days after your brother
had left for new york yes
yes because i was
[Music]
shocked at that
at that i was shocked at that um and
concerned that he was out of town and
didn't know if he
needed to be there he was gone you know
um and i was asking the attorney and
they said no he doesn't have to be there
no one has to be there amber won't be
there no one will be there just
attorneys it's a very simple process
did johnny attend the restraining order
hearing
no he was
not in town he wasn't in the country
you see any press coverage of the
restraining order hearing
yes i did
would you please
tell the jury what you saw or read
objection
not
asking for the proof of what was in the
articles to present sense impression
relevant
why is it relevant all right i'll
sustain it to hear saying relevance okay
did you see press co was there press
coverage of the hearing
there was a
tremendous amount of press coverage did
you read any of it
i did i did i did read some of it i did
you know i
saw
some of it
putting aside the truth or falsity of
what you saw what did you see
relevance
and what why is that wrong
how did you feel
when you read
the press relevance how the witness felt
is irrelevant what's the relevance
i think it
i think it's relevant to her testimony
or honor but i can move on okay i'll
sustain the objection next question
moving ahead two years
in time
did you see ms hurt's washington post
op-ed when it was published
in in december 18 2018.
yes
what did you think
miss herd's op-ed was about
relevance
it's entirely relevant they're they're
trying to argue somehow
that uh people didn't understand what
what the op-ed meant we we heard an
opening
where there was
ms dombrowski
have you had any discussions
with your brother
about the op-ed
yes
i'm not sure if it is or not it's a yes
or no question okay all right next
question
as
mr depp's brother
and as his personal
manager
do you have any understanding how the
publication of the op-ed
has affected your brother's career
objection foundation
your honor and hearsay
i i don't know if it's here's you oh i
apologize
that's fine but
she's worked with her brother
for
uh
let's see where the answer goes
you may answer
i'm sorry would you mind asking it again
do you have
an understanding of how the publication
of the op-ed has affected your brother's
career
yes
[Music]
the op-ed
the op-ed as written
um
with uh
the way it was written the wordings uh
within the op-ed make it very clear
of a time frame
director to answer that question again
maybe you should ask it again
how has the
publication of ms heard's op-ed putting
aside for a moment
its relationship to your brother
its references to your brother
how has it affected his career
i believe there's a negative effect on
anyone's career when there's accusations
you know
um
as as there have been
how has it affected him personally
objection foundation
she's his sister your honor
i'll allow it go ahead
personally
i know i know he
i know he doesn't want people to feel
that he
you know that he could ever be that type
of person which he
isn't and
to know that actually that is something
that is attached to him now
um
which trickles down to his children
you know where i think that part
more than anything
is the part that has
bothered him you know the fact that his
children have to
you know have this
in their life
ms dombrowski do you believe that your
brother physically abused miss hurd
objection your honor
foundation i'll sustain the objection
do you believe that miss heard is a
public figure representing domestic
violence
no i don't i believe the opposition
excuse me i'll sustain the objection
thank you thank you you strike that
answer please thank you
as his sister
and as his personal manager for decades
are you aware of any occasion on which
any woman other than misheard has ever
accused your brother
of any type of physical
abuse
objection foundation hearsay
i'll allow the answer
no
how has ms heard's op-ed
impacted your life
objection relevance what's the relevance
thank you honor that's all i have right
now i'll just draw a question okay all
right
cross examination
thank you
yes sir
good afternoon ms dabrowski
so i believe we covered some of this but
just want to make sure so you're
you're employed at a company your
brother owns right yes it's called
infinitive nile yes is that right and
it's mr depp's production company yes
and you're the president of that company
right yes
and that is your
only source of income
correct i have other projects that i
work on on the side it's your only job
right it's my full-time job yes right
and
um job-wise you don't have any other
sources of income other than infinitive
denial right
other projects i
i have i have the opportunity with other
projects to make more money okay
all right um
your honor may i approach all right if
you could just show counsel what you're
approaching with
it's just a copy for deposition
all right
you're just getting cut i think he's
just giving copies mr chu
oh i i assume it wouldn't be
okay
thank you
yes please
miss dombrowski do you remember giving a
deposition in this case yes
and
just a couple months ago right
i believe so yeah and you remember um
before you started that deposition being
under oath right yeah okay and you swear
to tell the truth yeah okay
and you were asked questions by counsel
for misheard and you gave answers right
yes
could you please take a look at page 19
of that deposition
transcript in front of you
i'm sorry
and do you see on page sorry page 19
line 8 through 10
you were asked the question do you have
any other sources of income other than
from infinity neil
nile
and you answered no job-wise no right do
you see that i do and was that testimony
correct
yes
but it's the same as what i said today
now
you have a huge financial interest in
your brother's career right
the money that infinitive nile makes
comes from money that mr debt makes
correct
it hasn't always historically known
what else has it come from
we've had
deals with other
entities companies and for the most part
the better your brother does in his
career the more money infinitive nile
makes though correct
i i i don't think it's exactly like that
no
and you have a uh
your brother has done projects that
infinitive nile has been the production
company for correct yes okay and you
have a financial interest in that
company correct
uh i'm an employee
are you employed by
his other companies as well i'm employed
by infinitive nile
are you employed by
the other companies that your brother
has no
do where do you receive your paycheck
from infinity infinite
and you have a financial interest in how
infinitive nile performs financially
correct
i i have a salary that i get so
that's not a financial interest if
you're asking if i get a piece of the
pie
no you're you wouldn't consider salary
financial interest so i i consider it a
salary yes it's but but it sounds like
you're asking something different i'm
sorry maybe i misunderstood yeah so the
bottom line is you draw a salary from
infinite nile yes and that's your
brother's production company correct yes
now
you feel protective of your younger
brother always have right yes and you
testified earlier today
about
mr depp's reactions to some of your
mother's anger growing up
how
how old was mr depp during the periods
you were talking about like when he was
a kid is that basically what you were
talking about
the reactions to mom's anger
began as when we were children and the
and
we have we've had the same reaction
always was to
leave
right and when you were testifying
earlier about mr depp's reaction being
to leave
you were referring to when he was
before you left the house when he was a
kid right
yes but we we left the house not too far
apart from each other but yes
when when mr depp would
leave as a child during the times when
your mother was angry at him was he
addicted to drugs back then
no was he addicted to alcohol no
you testified a little bit about mr
depp's um
former partner vanessa parady
you were friends with vanessa right we
were it was a family so right you
considered her family
right she was part of the family yes
right and you were friendly with her yes
you liked her yes you were happy that
your brother was with her
i was happy that my brother was happy
yeah and and you you didn't want to see
him split up from vanessa did you
you know what i i wanted
both of them to be happy i
it didn't matter to me if they split up
or not
you were you were devastated when they
split up weren't you
i don't think i was devastated were you
happy about it
no i wanted my
family to be okay
did what were your emotions when you
learned that your brother was splitting
from vanessa
if i had to say i was probably you know
a little sad for both of them but that i
mean beyond that
i i don't i don't really recall big
emotions
you were sad because you were losing her
as part of what you just testified was
your family right
no
you weren't sad about that no
now on may 21st um
2016 you're asking questions about that
and and i know
um
i know your mother's passing must have
been very tough so i'm not going to ask
specific questions about that
i'm going gonna ask questions about the
next day just to make sure that i had
your your your testimony right um
can you remind me you said you saw your
brother that the morning of may 21st
i stopped by there at some point in the
in the yeah in the daytime in the early
part of the day
what approximately what time
i i honestly don't remember was it
before
lunch
i i don't remember the timing it was
just daytime it was daytime and you
testified that
when you stopped by there for the first
time that day that you were
you were upset because it seemed like he
and amber had been fighting is that what
you said
i said that
they had been arguing
they had been arguing and i've said that
i
i didn't love that they were arguing on
it was a
horrible day to argue on
and and that was
your testimony was that you were upset
that they had been arguing when you
stopped by that during the daytime right
okay
um
now you have no understanding of
any of amber or mr depp's communications
leading up to may 21st correct
i don't know that i have a lot of that
no okay and but your testimony is that
when you stopped by during the daytime
on may 21st that
they had been fighting and that made you
upset is that right
i'm just trying to understand what you
testified to
it it's not that it made me upset i
found it upsetting
did you ever become aware that they
hadn't actually seen each other or
communicated at all before he came over
at 8pm on may 21st
she's testified that she
said that they were fighting earlier in
the day i'm asking her if she ever
became aware that they hadn't actually
seen each other talk that day
all right i'll allow the question just
go ahead
i'll ask it again did you ever become
aware that amber and mr depp hadn't seen
each other or talked that day before he
came to the eastern columbia building
the evening of may 21st
no i just know that when
what i understood was that they
had had a fight whether it was over the
phone or i don't know
they were arguing
now when your mother was
in the last days of her life in the
hospital
amber visited her right
amber did come one time
by herself if that's what you're
referring to she she did come one time
shortly before johnny was also coming
and she visited her actually more than
one time correct
i don't recall her visiting
on her own more than one time no i
remember her coming
one time because i didn't know she was
coming
um
and johnny was actually also coming
so they ended up there together
i guess i'm a little confused because
you just you just testified that she
only visited one time alone
this is what i'm saying i only remember
the one time
alone
where she showed up alone i only
remember one time and and johnny came
shortly after she was there and other
times she visited with johnny or other
people is that right she visited with
johnny sometimes
during the time that amber and johnny
were together
[Music]
you became aware that he was using
drugs and alcohol excessively correct
all right
your honor she's testified to what she
observed during their relationship i
think it's within the scope
no i'll rule the objection you can ask
the question good
did you want to ask the question again i
do yeah okay um
during the time that
amber and johnny were dating
did you become aware that he was using
drugs or alcohol excessively
i i became aware that he had been
drinking
and i
during the time they were dating i i
became aware of
at one point you know
a certain a certain medication yes
and you
form the opinion that not only had he
been drinking but he was drinking
excessively correct
i don't know that i formed excessively
but
he was drinking you you became aware
that he was using booze right
i knew he was drinking and you knew he
was using cocaine right
i never saw him do that so
you you became aware that he was using
cocaine correct
i never saw him use
anything like that
i became aware of people saying that
and you became so concerned about that
that you
told your brother to stop using cocaine
correct
i don't i don't i don't know that i
remember telling him to stop using
cocaine
i think
i might have told him anything that he
was doing
he should stop doing
heather can you pull off exhibit 214
please
your honor i'll obviously move for
admission before it's
published the journal that's fine i just
wanted to make sure it wasn't going to
be on their screen
can you can you flip it
oh
just trying to figure out how to rotate
this your honor if it's coming from her
computer screen you have to rotate it on
there i mean i figured all this is doing
is mirroring whatever was on
on the computer screen there's nothing
we can do
sorry for the delay around i appreciate
your patience
yes sir
okay
i don't
know do you want to unplug it and plug
it back in just to see
to the system
all right i think we have it
when you turn it off and on it works at
everything that's right that's the
secret
okay
all right
that looks better
miss dembrowski i'd like to
direct your attention to
the
um
the four texts in the middle of the page
um
if you look in the from column
there's a name that says christy
dembrowski and it has a number is that
your number
yes
and are those texts from you
to your brother
johnny depp
yes
and those texts were sent on or about
february 5th 2014
yes okay you're on our move for the
admission of um defendant exhibit two
one four
any objection to two one four
can i can i just say something no just
just wait ma'am just wait for a question
yes sir
so
i think
this
is
okay
apologize for the delay judge
all right so you're moving in 214 we'll
receive it redacted
yes correct okay
over objection that's fine
um
and you wanted to publish just the
redacted parts correct yes your honor
okay
that's fine right now you just have the
dates up is that what you want to start
with yes your honor okay you can publish
that to jerry
okay
miss sombrowski
just
because we we can only show part of this
page
do you see that these
you just testify these were text
messages between you and mr deb right
and do you see that these text messages
were sent
on february 5th 2014
yes the the bottom three okay
and those bottom three
you just looked at when we saw the whole
page and i know it's a little cumbersome
for the jury not seeing that but
you testify that the bottom three were
text messages from you to your brother
right yes okay heather could you just
scroll to the right
please
that's that's good thank you
so on february 5th
2014
you sent three texts to your brother
you sent one that said stop drinking
right
you said one that said stop coke right
yes so i assume you weren't talking
about the soft drink right
it doesn't appear to be you were talking
about cocaine correct
i don't know what these are in reference
to so
i remember they brought this up at my
deposition
and
these are something that they're
i don't know that i don't know if
there's more context to them i don't
know what they're in reference to i know
what they say but i don't know what
they're in reference to and what they
say is that on february 5th 2014
you were telling your brother johnny
depp to stop using cocaine correct
no
i wrote those words but i that's what
i'm saying i don't know that i was
telling him to stop doing that you know
in context it would be different it
could be a different scenario
well let's let's take it word word by
word coke when you wrote coke you meant
cocaine not the soft drink right
yeah okay and when you wrote pills you
meant prescription pills right yeah okay
so you were telling him on february 5th
2014 to stop drinking stop coke and stop
pills right
i wrote the words
and did you have any reason to believe
when you wrote that
that mr depp had been on a bender
recently
i don't recall writing this
so i don't recall the context of it
i understand that the words are there
but i don't
i don't recall the timing
or the writing
of it i don't recall anything about it
necessarily
you weren't joking when you wrote that
right it wasn't a joke right
i probably was not joking but but you
know
maybe i was repeating something that
someone else told me
to write
you were telling your brother to stop
drinking stop cocaine and stop pills
because you believed that he had a
problem with drinking cocaine and pills
correct
i didn't believe he had the problem
as much as uh
as much as someone else was trying to
make me believe that he had the problem
did you have any reason to believe that
mr depp had been on a recent bender
i didn't witness vendors i don't you
know what i mean so i'm not involved in
the vendors
understood i'm asking at the time when
you sent these three text messages on
february 5th 2014 did you have any
reason to believe that mr depp had been
on a recent bender i
i i couldn't tell you about february
whatever date that is back then and what
i would know at this moment
did you have any reason to be worried
about mr deb
when you sent these texts
again
i don't know what was happening in life
at that time i don't recall
that period the dates i don't recall
where we i don't recall anything about
that time
these
these texts
i know i know what the words are but i
don't know what the context is of them
right and so i'm asking you i'm asking
you a question as best i can which was
when you sent these texts did you have
any reason to be worried about mr depp's
use of
alcohol cocaine or pills
again i don't i don't recall
the time period of sending these texts
so i don't know that i would have any
reason at that time i don't know
would you have sent the text if you
didn't have a reason to be worried about
his use of alcohol cocaine or pills
i i could send those three separate
lines like that three separate texts i
could do that if
if it was
you know there's different reasons that
maybe i could do that it doesn't mean
that was me giving him a message have
you ever sent texts to anyone else to
tell them to stop drinking stop coke or
stop pills before
again i don't know that i'm telling him
to stop drinking stop coke and stop
pills that's what i'm saying it's the
context of this
and and i appreciate that but that
wasn't my question my question was have
you ever sent texts to anyone else
in your life telling them to stop
drinking stop coke or stop pills
i don't believe i've ever told anybody
to stop doing any of those things in a
text message but i also don't know that
that's what i was doing here is what i'm
trying to say but you wrote those words
to mr depp right
i wrote those words
and you didn't love the behavior that mr
depp was engaging in around this time
frame did you
i i don't know the time frame i don't
know
what time frame you're actually
referring to well around in the days
leading up on or around february 5th
2014 you didn't love the behavior that
johnny depp was engaging in
did you
i don't i don't
recall anyone's behavior
from february 2014 i don't recall
february 2014
would it would it refresh your
recollection perhaps to see other text
messages that you sent on around this
time to determine whether or not you
were worried about mr depp
if there's other contacts i guess i
don't know why don't we do this um
heather can you please pull up
exhibit 2
10.
your honor mad approach all right thank
you
miss dombrowski do you do you recognize
this document as a text message chain
between you and amber heard on february
3rd 2014
yes
and
you see the chain it starts at about 5
5 20 pm
right yes
and there's messages from from amber to
you are the ones on the right correct in
blue
yes
and messages from you to amber are the
ones in gray on the left right yes okay
and
if you go
well
take a minute and just just read that
first page please
so
does does this refresh your recollection
about a text conversation you had with
amber on or about february third two
thousand fourteen
well i i can see this is our text
exchange
and
um
does this refresh your recollection
about concern that you may have had
about the behavior that mr depp was
engaged in on around that time
again i
does this i'll ask it again does this
refresh your recollection about behavior
that mr depp may have been engaging in
around that time
it's
i remember i remember um
i remember this period and what amber
was believing that he was doing yes at
this period
and but does this refresh your
recollection about
your worry and concern for your brother
johnny depp around this time
i don't i don't still don't recall
having a severe worry around this time
okay well before you didn't recall me
any worry so does it does this at least
refresh your recollection that you had
some
i honestly i don't recall having to
worry i you know i i've had worries in
the years but i don't recall having to
worry at this time i don't recall it
okay um so so did you did you have any
reason to doubt
what you were reading from misheard in
these texts
to be honest
she was
she would write things quite often or
explain things quite often and
it's a bit more dramatic maybe than what
we understood it to be or or
um
maybe even sometimes the instances were
different
than what she was describing so
i
but in any event
this conversation that you had with miss
heard gave you concern enough to tell
your brother stop
coke stop pills stop booze right
no i don't think it did yeah it didn't
did
and i've asked this before but we can
we'll take a look at this
is it true you didn't love the behavior
he was engaging in around this time
right
again
i didn't witness a lot of the behavior
that
people are taught you know that you guys
are referencing i didn't witness a lot
of it
um take a look at page two please
and
just take a minute to read that then
i'll have some questions about both of
the pages
okay
what you had been told by miss heard on
the first two pages of these texts gave
you concern about mr depp's behavior and
made you not love anything that he was
engaging in behavior-wise around this
time right
what i had heard
from her in in these texts
i didn't really love where life was at
the time
you're honored i've moved for the
admission of these two pages in their
entirety for the reasons that we
discussed both as impeachment of the
witness
all right i i there are other statements
in here that i do find us hearsay so we
can work with it um
i'm not i'll reserve on that for this
time maybe and we'll have uh other other
issues with it outside the presence of
the jury and we'll work on redactions
okay ken that sounds good can i um
can i ask her questions just about her
language
and then we can work on redactions yes
sir
yes sir
on the first page your honor or i'm
sorry on the first page miss nombrowski
um
you write where are the kids
why did you write that
i
i don't know i mean i remember they
asked me that at the deposition i'm not
sure you wrote that because you had
concerns about where mr depp's kids were
at this time right
well if she was saying he wasn't home
i was asking where the kids were
right because you were concerned for the
kids well-being particularly when mr
depp was in this sort of state correct
no i was curious about where the kids
were if he wasn't home were you ever
concerned about
the impact on the kids of mr depp's drug
use and alcohol use
no
okay so when you wrote where are the
kids you had no concern for their actual
well-being
is that right
the concern it was it's not that kind of
concern
she's saying he's not home
i was wondering where the kids were so
that they weren't alone
when you wrote her on page
two
do you want to come to office to talk
you wrote that
because you were concerned about what
was going on with mr death at that point
right
no actually
i wrote that so that she could come to
the office so that we could talk
right about all of it
all of what of her text
your honor i asked for permission to
publish the bottom text on page two that
i think
it's not up here you just made her text
sorry
and i guess while she's pulling that up
i'd move for um partial admission of
exhibit 210 with redactions to be
again i'm going to reserve on that okay
all right that's
all right i'm still going to reserve on
the admission of it so i'm not going to
show it to the jury at this time okay
okay okay but you can ask your questions
about it okay thank you your honor
when you wrote miss heard
on february 3rd 2014 at 5 42 pm miss
dombrowski worry about everything
you were telling her to worry about
everything
and all the types of behavior that mr
depp was engaging in at that time right
i was not telling her to worry about
anything
that's the way i wrote that sounds like
i say i you know i worry about
everything
you're saying that you're worrying about
everything
is that right
yes as a whole okay so
in contrast to what you testified a few
minutes ago you actually were very
worried
around this time frame
correct
i was worried about what life was that's
what i said
and the life
that you were referring to here what was
going on in life was mr depp's drug and
alcohol abuse correct
what was going on in life was uh someone
who
constantly wanted to point out
some sort of drug and alcohol abuse is
that unfair for a spouse not to want
their
husband to
abuse drugs and alcohol it's not unfair
at all
so it was that a negative to you that
misheard didn't love that
i'm sorry was that a negative to you
that miss her didn't love mr depp's drug
and alcohol abuse
was that unreasonable of her
to me it was exaggerated as the problem
so it was exactly but but you testified
that you personally have no personal
knowledge of
your brother doing cocaine
i never saw him do it
okay but but you had enough concern to
text him stop doing
coke stop the pills and stop the
drinking correct
no i i really don't think that's what i
was doing with him
and
what were you tell you weren't talking
about the super bowl right you were
talking about drinking
i i understand i understand
but
the way it's written
and i know my writing the way it's
written i don't feel like
what i was doing was me giving him an
order to do that
i wouldn't typically do that
so recommending the other context
somewhere that you know for that right
and that's what we're trying to explore
is what is that context because
you're very direct in those texts that
the jury just looked at stop the booze
stop the pills stop the coke
so if you weren't telling him to stop
the booze stop the pills and stop the
coke what were you telling him
i could have been telling him that
you know
because i've had this conversation
before uh i could have been telling him
you know that in order to make her
not
constantly accusing
you know this is what she
would
need
right you didn't write those words in
your text though right no i didn't okay
and when you said uh in the february
third text message exchange with ms
heard i don't love any of it
i really want to be able to talk with
him
that was you expressing concern
about mr depp's drinking and drug use
correct
that was me expressing concern about
what life was
and it was there was arguments all the
time and
it was it felt like there was just
constant
unpleasantness
right and would it be unfair
well
let me ask it this way
that unpleasantness to your knowledge
was caused
in part at least by
your brother's drug and alcohol abuse
right
i don't know that
did you ever
reach your own conclusion
that your brother
had a problem with drugs and alcohol
i knew my brother was drinking um
i'm sorry
i knew my i knew my brother was drinking
um
but in terms of like
drugs i you know honestly there was
i had only
one medication that i really
knew of that you know was an issue for
him and what was that i don't remember
the name of the medication it was a
prescription medication
what was the what was it
it was a it was like a pain medication
that he had been taking for a long time
and that was what you were referring to
when you said stop pills was
prescription pain medication correct
again
i wasn't necessarily referring to
anything in particular i know i wrote
those words i don't know the context of
the words okay but in any event you you
don't dispute that on february 5th 20
20
whatever date that was on february 5th
2014 you wrote your brother stop
drinking stop coke stop pills right
i i wrote those words but i don't know
the context of the words
now
february 2014 wasn't the first time
that
you had
had communications with miss heard
relating to concerns about
drug and alcohol abuse right by mr deb
correct
i i don't know
um
heather if you could pull up exhibit 163
please
what's exit number i'm sorry oh i'm
sorry you're on one six one six three
while she's pulling that up miss
dembrowski
let me ask you this
you knew
that
mr depp's drug and alcohol problem was
affecting his relationship with miss
heard right
i knew that she would say that i mean i
knew that she would say that she had
issues with
you know him with drugs and alcohol
and and and you knew from those
communications that it was negatively
impacting their relationship right
um
i knew that she would she would write me
about them
you know and i knew that she would i
know that she would uh
you know try to
try to
you know try to uh talk about them but
and i know that she would say that they
were negatively impacting i don't know
that that was the whole
situation that they had going on to be
honest though well you didn't disbelieve
her when she told you that right
when she told me
what you just testified too
that drinking and drugs were negatively
impacting their relationship you didn't
disbelieve her right
oh i i didn't necessarily think it was
true no you didn't think it was true
that it was negatively impacting the
relationship
i didn't necessarily think it was 100
true no well
you just said true and then 100 percent
true so i'm trying to try to figure out
how to try to figure out where you're
going with this
is it your testimony today that you
never believed misheard when she would
talk to you about johnny's drugs and
drinking
no i think you're taking it to an
extreme well that's what i'm trying to
get at i'm sorry if i am so just explain
to me what
is that's not your testimony i think she
i think she exaggerated things quite a
bit
you tried to help amber deal
with mr depp's drugs and drinking
correct
i tried i tried to uh make sure that i
was helpful to amber
as best i could yes
if you can look at the
document in front of you exhibit 163
please
this is a text exchange between you and
miss heard
on march 22nd
2013.
correct
yes
and
do you remember earlier you testified
about um
uh being present during the filming of a
documentary about keith richards
yes this was this was right around that
time frame correct
i
i don't know do you recall when that was
i don't recall the dates and actually
one thing i wanted to ask you about that
while we're at it is you testified
earlier about not seeing cuts or or or
bruises on her face you remember that
do you
you don't you you have no knowledge
whether she was wearing makeup or not
that night right
i don't recall if she was wearing makeup
or not she typically did not okay and
you weren't specifically looking
for cuts or bruises because you
suspected that
mr deputy abused abuser right i would
have no reason to look for cuts or
bruises but i would think if they were
there i would see them okay
um
so if you look at page one uh
exhibit 163 um
and you're on right
move for permission to publish
[Music]
i'm gonna sustain that objection i
figured you would okay can i do the same
thing and ask her about her words to
misheard and then we can reserving the
right to publish it to the jury
refreshes her memory about the
conversations you're trying to discuss
yes
so um
ms dembrowski
do you recall having a conversation with
miss heard
on her about march 22nd 2013
in which miss heard was expressing
concerns to you about mr deff's behavior
no i i don't recall dates so no
okay um
why don't you go ahead and take a look
at this document
please
and let's just
let's start with um
just tell me when you're done with page
one please
oh
mr nebraska i think i think that's you
you on the screen which is okay if you
want to mark it out though
we got it i didn't oh i'm sorry oh okay
doing their own redactions okay
okay i've read it okay
so um
when when you when you texted miss heard
well first of all does this refresh your
recollection about uh a conversation
that you and miss heard had on march
22nd 2013 relating to
ms hurt's concerns about mr jeff's
behavior
it really doesn't but i
i see it here but you don't dispute that
it is a conversation that the two of you
had
this is a text exchange between the two
of us yes when you wrote don't be sorry
exclamation point i am not completely
sure if what is going on
or why but i don't love what it is what
did you mean by that
i'm i'm not 100 sure i believe i
probably meant
once again
you know
how life was
right life including mr depp's conduct
toward my client amber heard right
yeah okay and
when you wrote it is sad and i'm sorry
you guys are going through this i'm here
if there's anything i can do
you were talking about the chat you were
sad that they were going through the
challenges that drugs and alcohol on
behalf of mr deb we're posing to their
relationship
correct
if she can answer
i i don't think that i'm saying that i'm
sad about that i'm i'm saying that i'm
sad you know about whatever it is that
you know that they're going through but
i don't know exactly what it is that
they're going through right and write
two texts underneath that misheard tells
you what they're going through right
she does go into uh about yeah what they
have going on and then below that you
say i think with anyone in that place
confrontation unfortunately doesn't help
and sometimes conversations can seem
like confrontations do you see that
were you suggesting to miss herd that
she shouldn't have a conversation with
mr depp about what drugs and alcohol did
to him
because it could seem like a
confrontation
no
no i was not suggesting that at all um
what did you mean by it
honestly what i was trying to do um is
trying to uh
amber misheard um
she she could be very very vocal
and so what i was trying to do was if
they were having a conversation if it
wasn't going well i was trying to tell
her that you know maybe
you know sometimes conversations if
you're
vocal really loud they're more
confrontational like just to whatever it
is just have a nice easy conversation
okay well let's just go to the i just
want to look at one more text on the top
of the next page heather please
when you write misheard
on march 22 2013
you say disagreeing
reasoning
nudging all can seem like confrontations
i am not sure of the volume
or when some is likely to wear off
question mark
first of all
when you were talking about volume or
when some is likely to wear off
you're talking about drugs or alcohol
correct
she said in the text prior
right
i'm asking
i understand i'll sustain the objection
and i'm asking what you're you're
referring to
without referring to mrs hurt's text
prior when you say i'm not sure of the
volume or when some is likely to wear
off what are you referring to i don't
know i mean that's what i'm that's what
i'm trying to say is you know she had
all kinds of things that she said in the
text prior i'm referring to like
volume of
you know even just voices you know that
even you can see where i say like you
know the nudging and all of that but
you know there was a certain way that
you learned to try to talk with amber to
keep things calm
and when you okay and when you said once
i thought she was all right you're
pretty sure
mr two that's fine
thank you i appreciate it i understand i
i let her finish her first answer that's
fine
thank you thank you um
there was a certain way that you know
ultimately we
you learn to talk to amber you know to
sort of keep things calm so
you would pacify her you would sort of
you know
just go along with all of her
conversations whatever so that you could
we would placate her all the time to
keep things calm that's what we did and
and and
so when you said disagreeing reasoning
nudging all can seem like confrontations
were you telling miss heard that she
shouldn't voice any concerns about
her significant other's drug or alcohol
abuse
voice her divorce any concerns to who to
him
that she shouldn't nudge him about it or
try to reason with him about drug and
alcohol abuse or his behavior
is that what you were saying that you
shouldn't do that because it might seem
like a confrontation
no she was more confrontational she was
much more confrontational always
confrontational and i was trying to say
that all of these things
can be confrontational and maybe maybe
take it down a notch okay so you
shouldn't disagree or reason or nudge is
that what you were saying
no
in the in the way that i know that it
would be done she was much more
uh
she wasn't a
you know there wasn't a comforting
conversation i'm sorry sorry
were you done with your answer
i think so okay
or do you believe that disagreeing with
someone or trying to reason with them or
nudging them
justifies them getting abused
as the foundation i'll sustain as the
foundation okay
do you have any
um
have you ever disagreed with or reasoned
with or nudged anyone in anything in
your in your life
all right i mean
these are the words that she wrote
i know these are the words that you
wrote to my client disagreeing reasoning
nudging all can seem like confrontations
i'll allow the question
i'm sorry have you ever disagreed or
reasoned or nudged with someone in your
life
yes okay
do you believe that doing any of those
three three things would justify you're
being abused
i'll sustain the quest
okay thank you
all right
um how much more do you have
probably a little bit a little bit okay
since it's five o'clock all right about
an hour okay all right ladies and
gentlemen since it's five o'clock we're
gonna go ahead and release you for the
day okay just a reminder as as always
please don't do any outside research
don't do uh don't talk to him any about
this case don't look at the news don't
watch anything on tv don't read the
papers and do
and and just
have a good calm peaceful night okay and
we'll see you tomorrow bright and early
okay thank you
well a hard copy of 210.
thank you
all right miss
dombroski just a reminder that you are
still under oath and you're still
testifying so since you're still
testifying you can't have any
discussions with anybody to include uh
mr depp's attorneys or his legal team
okay all right and we'll see you
tomorrow morning all right if you could
leave the courtroom i just have a few
mr depp as well correct correct and mr
yes anybody okay just don't talk about
your testimony to anybody okay all right
that's fine if you guys see outside the
uh courtroom i just have a few
housekeeping matters i want to take care
of
you can sit down it's okay if you want
to stand up that's fine i just wanna
let me finish this one issue first okay
i'd appreciate it um all right going
back to the text so on 163 are you still
trying to admit that into evidence that
was the last one
all right there's objection to
that
okay
all right
yes sir um anything further to say on
163 well i think
yeah yes two things at a minimum miss
dembrowski's text should be able to come
in because those aren't you're saying
even if we have to redact out all of
these hurts which
if that's what you're undergoing as we
can
the problem is and the reason i think
it's not hearsay is that it's
impeachment under 607 a7 i understand
your impeachment issue and i and i
understand that and that we'll go back
to 210 and i think there's an issue with
impeachment there but here i don't see
any impeachment basis to have the
extrinsic evidence in you got the
testimony in but i don't see a basis to
have the extrinsic evidence and i would
still ask the
um
not the impeachment they're not hearsay
they're probative to this case that
she's expressing
concern even if the jury can't see
they can't since they don't have the
context i'm not going to allow them in
so i'm going to deny i'm going to
sustain the objection to 163. as far as
210 the
the only impeachment basis
was when she testified that she didn't
recall anything about a bender or him
being on a bender so i think for
impeachment
purposes just the only part that comes
in is the um
as far as ms heard's text is um
the uh
jd is on a bender and not even the last
part of the
left that's it okay everything else
would have to be redacted
i'm going to allow that just that one
part that one part of everything else
gets redacted as far as her text miss
dombroski's text can come in except you
have to get rid of her identifying
information as far as her phone number
okay
that's it
okay i understand
okay all right that's fine noted thank
you
that's exactly right not the last two
words and not the sentence above it and
not the any of the sentences below it or
any of the other texts but mr brosky's
texts come in but you get it just take
out her her phone number for me
okay so if you can give me you owe me
that and i'll i'll allow the redacted
one into evidence
um and you can owe that to me tomorrow
okay
and you also owe me 214 tomorrow too
correct
yes
one on that one um
can we if we get the last two columns if
we redact the personal identifiers
can we then show the other course
columns that correspond to the text
as long as the personal identifiers what
was what the objection was so if you
could do that for just the four yes yes
sir and get rid of the others okay all
right all right that's all i had yes
ma'am you had something
okay
thank you
you